be nice if we had this recorded doing
this
as acting chair of the House Education
committee I find that due to the estate
of emergency declared by the governor
result of the covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with the house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant the executive order 2020 24
this is public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a full
committee work s work session of bills
referred to the education committee
executive session on pending leg
legislation may be held I doubt that
please note that there's no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporar come yeah
to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order I am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate during the
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by Zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information have been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice that this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA 91a
anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email HS le. state. n. Us in
the event the public is unable to access
the meeting meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled I want to introduce
staff at the meeting assisting us this
morning Jennifer 4 committee researcher
please note that all votes are taken
this me should be done by roll call but
I don't think we're doing any votes
let's start a meeting by taking the roll
call attendance when each member states
a place please St presid please also
State whether there's anyone in room
with you during this meeting which is
required on the right to no law okay
this done sort out
alphabetically Mr chair yes am I taking
am I performing clerk duties today no no
we don't really need one
session so representative all here in
the Legislative Office Building
representative Andrews here home alone
in
Salsbury I'm here uh representative
cordelli is here he'll be no he's not
there representative Cornell
here representative Ellison
uh present here at my home alone in
coner representative Ford home alone in
Chester present representative Hobson
here here in the committee room lad is
here he'll be back in a minute
representative Leon she's here she's
running an errand right now
representative
Lakers I saw you you're
muted you're still
muted okay she's here try to figure how
to unmute
yourself representative
[Music]
Le I'm substituting for representative
leay this morning representative Bo who
Marie Porter oh
okay I'm home alone in hillsb okay
repres know
here oh represent lakus I see you can
being
connected okay you're still muted anyway
no problem representative maet here in
the house group representative Mullen
here in beautiful Bedford representative
Miler here in kukic my home
office represent sha she's still
probably recuperating
wish your
well representative sod here in the
committee room representative
Tana T I don't see not
here represent Woodcock here in CER
Conway with my dog and my wife after she
plays nine okay thank you
so my phone bomb my whole computer
bombed just as you were calling okay
back I'm home Tony May out and I'm still
sick now unfortunately we can hear you
yeah I
know okay this this is the work session
uh hopefully um Rick and Glenn will be
back here shortly so the idea is to
figure out what what we want to do or
get some consensus on bills for our exec
session next week so we'll start with um
Senate bill for 44 establishing New
Hampshire work forth passway program um
so first I guess open it up for anybody
has any comments on
this
nobody well I guess I'll give
mine well I think I mean we have right
now I don't think this is needed right
now because unemployment is way down um
it' be nice though if this add it so
people can get a CDL license because
that seems to be what's needed
throughout the state and Country but
anyway I
think with the unemployment being we're
3% now and jobs all over and we're doing
away with uh you know people looking for
jobs um I personally don't think it's
needed but
anyway and you got any other comments
well I think Ralph this does this this
bill does provide uh an opportunity uh
to
re-engage uh some of those
notwithstanding the help wanted that we
do see I I think this provides an
opportunity for individuals who are
currently unemployed or
underemployed uh to seek alternative
sources for their work career and I I
don't think there should be anything
that we should do here that would
prohibit the opportunity for people to
advance themselves and it seems to me
that uh this program and working with uh
the Department of Labor and security
recognize that there are there should be
options for people to advance themselves
and I I would not want to frankly stand
in the way of uh individuals uh learning
different things and uh advancing their
their work
career Porter has her hand repres
Porter thank you Mr chair for for
allowing me to speak um I think I have
to agree with representative Miler and
if if we remember prior to the pandemic
if I remember correctly we had critical
work Workforce shortage in critical
areas um businesses were crying out for
people who were specifically trained for
certain jobs um and and I can't imagine
that that has gone away uh and when
things come back those needs will still
be there and a program like this would
offer a pathway for someone to get the
certification certification or the
education that they need to to join
those professions so I I I looked at it
as a as a helpful tool for people who
were underemployed or trying to make
their lives better by leaving a low
skill job and going to a higher skill
job representative
Cornell okay I just want to agree with
melan marjerie um one of the things that
said was underemployed New Hampshire
adults um to gain more skills and some
of the testimony was from the auto
dealers who were speaking on behalf of
500 businesses who asked that they
needed more skilled workers and I'm also
on the um CTI advisory Council where all
the business people that are on that
Council are saying they're having a hard
time finding people with the skills to
go into their their places of work and
they're have and they are willing to
help train them but they they need help
and they they want them to go into like
the community college and they'll work
along with them but it's it's not the
the unemployment signs that are out on
the streets I don't think is targeted
toward this bill
that's all representative
Ford yes uh the Career and Technical
education people are very supportive of
this it links in with their efforts to
get people trained in very specialized
fields that requires some of the
certifications were talked about in in
various committees that we've we've uh
discussed these issues in and I I would
be very supportive of this I I think it
ties in very much with their their
efforts to train the workforce and the
whole Workforce program idea and so I'm
I'm very much in support of this bill
represent
valet yes thank you Mr chair uh does not
the community college system have the
authority to create this program now for
themselves why do they need legislation
to create an internal program they want
the federal
money uh represent like
us you still
muted I'm just wondering what this does
that's not already being done by all of
these things is the difference just that
it's somehow it's being paid
[Music]
for yeah I mean point is the auto
dealers already
funding the community college for that
kind of stuff I think a lot of it comes
down to reading it it's the tap into the
federal money that's being offered like
for the Community College um but I don't
know
anyway uh let's see representative
Mullen yeah thank you very much uh
representative boam there are two things
that caught my attention one is that
there is no cost to the individual for
the training that is being offered
through this program so I think you're
right I think harnessing some of the
monies that are available to us and
using it to benefit underemployed or
unemployed people is one thing and then
the second thing is at the end of the
bill it talks about um businesses uh and
training facilities working to come up
with incentive programs to attract
workers so I think that that's probably
a pretty important part of this as well
because as we all know we can have the
jobs but if we don't attract the people
to fill the positions then they sit
empty uh representative wood thank you
thank you Mr chair I would agree with
representative M that was one of the
points I want to indicate that that is a
recruitment effort with we currently
haven't had is the key piece the other
one is that some folks have alluded to
there isn't a financial note because
it's part of the
the federal Workforce opportunity
resources money but I do like the
collaboration and and putting together
Employment Security as well as economic
development and uh our community colle
system which hasn't been there before as
a Triad so I think those two pieces in
itself I just provide more opportunity
the more we can advertise and train
those that want to move up as
representative Cornell said I I concur
with them 100% thank you I got a
question for anybody out there shouldn't
at least this bill have a sunset
provision saying once the federal money
goes away this goes
away I would be in support of that um at
the end of the federal funding having a
sunset Clause otherwise it has to come
out of the budget
so had her hand raised at one point I
put back
down okay so I think we'll end the
discussion on 40 4 and when we have
exact session we can go over this again
so our next one is one of I call the
representative home I didn't I don't
know if Louise wanted to speak or not um
can you just give me a thumbs up or
thumbs down did you have something well
we're not
taking this isn't a hearing so we're not
open to the public for given comments
Lou Andrews oh
Louise I didn't I'm sorry didn't see and
okay representative
Andrew yeah thank you Mr chair my only
question was and I think deor Hobson
answered it is what are we going to do
when this Federal money comes to an end
I mean I don't believe we can go back to
New Hampshire taxpayers and have them
pick up the bill and so there really
needs to be a lot of thought put into
you know what are we going to do because
the government has a tendency of giving
us money and when they want to they yank
it back thank
you agree that's why I think we need a
uh there's at least need an amendment
for sunset provision Mr chair um if I
may I see that uh we do have Shannon
Reed who is is a representative from the
community college system in our attendee
list I'm wondering if she might be able
to give us some clarity around some of
the questions that we've had around uh
the availability of current uh options
for Community College Etc I mean could
we invite her in if she has some
comments on this particular
Bill if if she wants to yes
okay welcome to education
[Music]
Shannon hi Shan go ahead
good morning can you hear me yes all
right thank you um thanks for the
opportunity I I guess what I I would say
just a few quick things um first we
wouldn't be seeking an appropriation
even in the absence of federal funds for
this um for this effort we think that
there's enough sources of funds kind of
already available to us um to do what we
need to do and in fact there's really
not an extra cost to doing the types of
of efforts that are within House Bill 4
Senate Bill 44 um the few things the
things that we like about it just
quickly it creates a for a more formal
mechanism it brings some shape and
structure to efforts which are which
exist in the state but are probably more
siloed than uh they ought to be for
optimal impact on New Hampshire
residents and job Seekers and businesses
um I think that our low unemployment
figures in New Hampshire probably mask a
low labor force participation and I
think that there are people out there
who could really use some focused
short-term training to find good um and
you know good jobs better jobs than
those that they have or or might have
recently lost um this program would help
us to work with partners and and
identify Pathways for folks to gain
skills and reenter um you know
potentially higher skill higher paying
jobs and it does in fact position the
state I think more uh strongly for for
competitive federal grants where where
the grantor can see that we have
a coordinated effort to bring to bear on
this issue of
Workforce a question foran
um in the community college system now
currently what percentage I mean a
number of people looking I mean in the
Past coming out trying to get a
certificate or a badge or whatever for
upping their education not now
exists I think it's hard for me to
answer that question with Precision
because people will come to our colleges
with multiple and sometimes you know one
person will have multiple goals but you
know I'd say well over half are are
really focus on that career credential
um in the first instance and then they
might have a goal kind of beyond that to
continue their education but you know
probably half to three quarters easily
are are here come to us for that next
step
professionally thank
you okay how can I
yes Miss Reed if I could ask you a
question um thank you for allowing me
the opportunity that um there's already
a program or it seems to be a program
that is the auto dealers reaching into
the CTV um schools and I was just
wondering if is that um not working or
do you need an alternative demographic
not really
sure um that that this would be doing
anything different than is already being
done it seems like we're working really
hard to find those workers wherever we
can already so how was sure thank you
for for that question you know I think
if every industry sector functioned as
the auto dealers did New Hampshire would
be uh even stronger economically that is
a that is an association of of um of
businesses that band together to
strengthen their Workforce Pipeline and
they do that in a number of ways I think
that that industry frankly can serve as
a model to to others I mean the auto
dealers Association work together to
help uh help Infuse our curriculum um at
the college level and the CTE level to
raise funds for scholarships to have um
events that promote the the industry
sector as a whole and and promote the
job Pathways they work with us to create
Co-op experience for students kind of
Soup To Nuts they they work with the
education uh sector to make sure that
there's a pipeline you know in fact I
think that that is that is a model I
know that the auto dealers supported
this do support this bill because I
think they just be the potential for
expanding the type of work that results
in a strong and ongoing pipeline for
high demand industry
sectors go ahead could I could I ask a
followup so it seems to me that maybe
you think this this type of a pathway
program could be replicated in other
Industries is that kind of the goal I I
think that's could certainly be within
the community college system in the last
few years we've developed apprenticeship
programs in healthcare manufacturing it
we're working on hospitality and
construction trades um you know I think
there's a lot of potential um and you
know in New Hampshire we're very we're
very fortunate we have a lot of people
and entities that have identified the
right set of challenges and and problems
and even Solutions but bringing bringing
those efforts together around a table I
think could really result in um in
benefits to the state thank
you thank you thank you very much okay
then with that I'll end a 44 and move on
to 147 which is one of the
Senate Omnibus Bill or I call ominous
bill
so so this is the bill
to adopting Omnibus legislation relative
to student a the central registry
Transportation students and special
education course part one
relative for filing an application for
federal student aid or the faster
application anybody got any comments on
part
one represent H thank you Mr chair um I
appreciate the motive behind having
every student fill out of FAA um however
it is rather intrusive for the families
that won't qualify for federal aid to be
required to fill out a form when they
know that there is no chance of this a
and that that would be taking away
resources from all of these departments
to review these applications that will
be thank you anybody else I don't agree
with that and right now I mean when my
granddaughter going the the uh there
there are organizations that go around
to the high schools in the junior year
at the state well I can't think of the
name of it but they inform students on
what to do and how to do it and also
most uh high school
counselors also already doing this so
personally I don't think it it's needed
it's like you said if everybody you know
everybody doesn't need to do it or will
do it anyway and I even when I do my
taxes big question comes up do you want
to do do a faf up so people are getting
that in all that questions anyway um
okay so any any other comments on
represent Luna oh thank you very much Mr
chair I think what you might be missing
on this though is that there is a waiver
um that can be um can be filed so that
if if the condition exists like what you
just laid out what you and
representative Lon laid out that that
there's no chance that they're going to
um receive financial aid or something
like that then they can file the waiver
with their with the local school
principal it um doesn't go through the
um the New Hampshire Department of
Education and I think um uh we do have a
representative um uh Mr applebe uh who
can uh who can testify again that it's
not collect the waiver is not being
collected by the uh by the department of
Ed and so it's a very very simple
process but um but for people that uh
that that for students that that are are
not considering going on to high higher
education um whether that's a a a
credential uh high value um certificate
like what we just talked about um in the
in Senate Bill 44 uh because they they U
think that they can't afford going ahead
and doing that this opens a lot of doors
it opens doors for for our Workforce it
opens doors for our constituents and and
it really doesn't have any um you know
it doesn't do doesn't um set up any
hurdles for um uh for anybody uh to
graduate um to graduate high school and
States like Louisiana uh who have rolled
this where they've rolled this out it's
been very successful so so um I hope um
the committee would uh would um support
this um initiative very strongly L uh
thank you Mr chair while I appreciate um
that that motive this would require
families with a higher income to file a
waiver and basically say we make too
much money that can bring other
discrimination in the school and that
brings personal financial information
into the hands of the principal and
that's not appropriate we may have
another way to increase backs of
participation but requiring everybody
either to make sure that they provided
their personal financial information or
say we're too rich for this is is an
invasion of
privacy
thank you Mr chairman uh not to sound of
stous
but what if I just don't want to fill
out a faster why should I have to seek a
high school principal permission not
to that that that's an egregious
invasion of my my choice to fill it out
or not fill it out it seems to
me representative
Ellison thank you Mr chairman uh I I
would certainly support what
representative luno has said uh and and
in addition it appears to me on the
waiver there's nothing that requires a a
family to State their income right
they're just making it up in in the b in
the bill uh I I guess my main point
would be that we have lots and lots of
students who
graduate uh who for a iety of reasons
don't think they can go on to higher
education they they don't know that that
uh Aid exists they don't know how to get
it and I see this as a bill which we
helping get more students into that
pipeline whether it's community college
or university because they will be aware
that there's financial aid available and
otherwise they don't know that thank you
repres
thank you Mr chair um under the waiver
Clause uh Mr chair I I didn't see
anything that said it had to go with the
principal it just says it goes to the
school district that could be a guidance
contct could just be a file that they
check off and if I recall from the
testimony they said one of the the
beauties of this program is that they
have taken the 100 questions that
typically involved in the big fast and
get it down 18 simplified ones so it's
not a big uh process just seems to me it
opens the door for anyone who wants to
go and it forces the school system in
all guidance councils to help all
youngsters fill out this form that may
have had difficulty with it before so I
think I think it's a pretty good thing
actually and I don't see it as invasion
of privacy um there may be someone from
the school department on the list could
identify that for us answer the question
but I don't see anything on the waiver
at least in the law that talks about
what the requirement is for disclosing
Financial maybe a waiver just says I
don't want to participate for whatever
reason it could be a youngster not going
to you're going to the military for
instance okay so if someone from the doe
was there could answer that question
that'd be terrific about it regarding if
in fact the waiver has financial
responsibilities on it represent Hopson
thank you Mr
chair no that's okay go
ahead I said but go ahead oh thank you
Mr chair uh this proposed law says shall
okay so if this becomes law then people
shall file a an application or shall
fire a waiver so my question is if
somebody breaks the law and does not
file either one of these what is the
sanction I don't know if somebody can
answer that
but I I don't know rep okay um I had a a
question for rep luno um is it okay if I
ask another yeah this this is a work
session so we can be somewhat I just I
just wanted to ask you um re know you
said that another state was um working
this program and had implemented it and
it was successful I can't remember the
state that you mentioned but I was
wondering if you could tell me um what
is the goal of a successful program like
this what are they trying to
achieve do that make sense that question
no no no I think that's I think that's a
good question and um and I think what
they've seen in um in Louisiana is that
uh is that more students have have
completed the FAFSA and are able to uh
to um pursue opportunities in higher
education whether that's at an
Associates level or Bachelor or fouryear
level or even with a um with high value
certificates so so I think that's how um
how they
success thank you very much represent
Mila U thank you Mr chair uh I I see
that we have Steve applebe in the uh
attendees list he might be able to we
admit him he might be able to answer
some of these questions uh but uh the
one the point I wanted to make is that
it it would seem to me that the policy
of this committee should be to encourage
the advancement of an individual's
education and one of the things that we
did find when we did the SAT test uh
when we uh implemented that several
years years ago as a result of students
who would not ordinarily have taken the
SAT test they took the SAT test and
found that they were competitive with
other students and in fact encouraged
them by taking the test seen how well
they did to pursue further higher
education I view this part one of this
omnus bill in a similar kind of a light
that once somebody body would file these
forms they may in fact find that they
they they can get uh funding to advance
their education and that's why I think I
would I would support this but I would
encourage you Mr chair to admit Steve
applebe to see if in fact he might be
able to answer some of the questions
that we've been dealing with here thank
you represent
Porter thank you Mr chair and please
excuse my ignorance on asking this
question not as familiar with the
education issues as you folks are but
aren't there other things that we
require students to do before they
graduate Civic task I mean isn't there
some don't they have to take certain
tasks and don't they have to go through
certain things before they can graduate
and would this not just be another one
of those
things file a FAFSA or give us a waiver
that you're not going to file a
f I think this is to me it's
intrusive represent
lakas he still
muted like he still muted oh there you
go
sorry brain's not working today can you
tell me what all kinds of monies uh the
FAFSA makes available to
students basically they say whether or
not you're you can get financial aid
yeah but does that include is that loans
or
grants
both both I remember doing it for my
granddaughter
um okay let let's call on Mr
applebe
hey Mr applebe I'm going to promote
you welcome to
education hi there okay you're there
good morning Miss have you been
listening to this
conversation um I I will apologize the
State Board of Education meeting is also
going on right now so I've been
listening to both so that happy to help
with any questions as best I can okay
basically it's I think the thing
revolves around why should people not
planning on on wanting to do the faster
um are not planning on going to college
maybe going into the military have to
file a waiver and I think that's the big
contention we
have do you have any insight on
that um well I you know in my reading of
the bill right it appears that the State
Board would engage in R making to
develop a form for the districts and
then distribute that form to the
districts and then from that point
forward it appears to be the the
district's responsibility to enforce the
statute and collect forms from p
um the think says
shell F that waiver the bill so what
would happen if the student
refuses or the parents
refuse any any idea on that well I'm I'm
not an attorney and um uh but I in my
reading I I of the proposed language um
I'm not not sure what would happen
um lay um thank you Mr appelby and Mr
chair I have a question about how much
of a burden this is going to place on
the districts I know that later today
we're discussing s SP 135 because people
families aren't returning the free and
reduced meal forms and that's been a
significant effort in a significant cost
in my U um is this something where the
school district are going to have to
dedicate people and resources in order
to follow up on these encourage these
students and uh make this a new part of
the recordkeeping and a significant new
effort uh thank you for the question
representative I I don't want to speak
on behalf of the districts my
recommendation might be to check with
the Schoolboard Association or the um uh
nhsaa potentially and and for an opinion
of the
districts thank
you repres woodcot do you have a
question
for I do thank you re chairman Mr thank
you very much for taking my question uh
it goes back to the waiver and as I was
listening to speak it it seemed to me
that the waiver has not been created um
with a document so this may be a mute
question one of the concerns are raised
by uh representative Leon was the
disclosure of potential Financial wealth
or not thereof for youngsters filling
out form the waiver form is it possible
on the on the uh development of the
waiver form that there was no
requirement to indicate Financial need
just say I he by wave so this is not uh
part of the
issue um so again I don't want to speak
for the state board when they create
rules uh to support this form but I
don't see anything in the legislation
that requires this the form to contain
financial information either way thank
you thank you thank you mby thank you Mr
chair any further question for M
Appleby saying none thank you Miss
applebe for thank you all thank you Mr
chair
okay uh representative
lakas you
go um I'm just trying to figure out what
we do about the students whose parents
generally don't comply with anything my
um a girl that we kind of unofficially
fostered for years we had all kinds of
opportunities fully paid for her her mom
just had to fill out a form and it never
happened and I'm wondering what do we do
about those kids because her mom
wouldn't fill out a waiver either does
she not graduate because her mom's you
know she's already had she already had
enough rough things in her life had
having a a no father and a
mostly um I don't know what word to use
to describe her mom but mostly non mom
um I don't know I just worry about she
is not she was not unique I know there
are other kids in the same kind of boat
and I just wonder what do we do about
those kids if we mandate this she didn't
she wasn't an adult until after she
graduated so right yeah that's that was
by thing I mean sh so what's the penalty
I mean yeah there nothing there
representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair I really
question this part of the
bill because many of our schools and I
know our school district we spend
thousands and thousands of dollars in
high school every year for guidance
counselors now to my knowledge guidance
counselors a student is assigned to each
to one of them and they are to help the
students so uh my question is are we
just adding another layer of bureaucracy
that isn't needed thank
you representative
M thank you Mr chair um to
representative lec's concern about that
child that doesn't have the adult
support um I think Roman numeral 2 takes
care of that representative leus because
it makes us statement that says uh a
school district shall award a high
school diploma to a student who is
unable to meet the requirements of
paragraph one due to extenuating
circumstances so I I would think as
determined by the school so I I would
think that if a student you know doesn't
have the parental support or whatever
then they would be able to appeal to
said guidance counselor or whatever and
it would be considered to be an
extenuating circumstance um I agree with
you I was concerned about the impact of
shell until I recognized that there was
an escape hatch there um and with
regards to representative Andrew's um
comment on school counselors um handily
I happen to be a school counselor so I
will uh comment a little bit on that um
the FFA is considered to be within the
domain currently of the parent so um
other than just directing a student to
where they could access the form the
school counselor wouldn't have much to
do
with the followup on that because the
the school is not you know technically
involved in the FSA at this point
however um I don't think it would be
burdensome for a counselor to have it on
the checklist of things that have to be
done and uh to be able to review with a
the student whether or not it has
happened okay thank you re Le um thank
you Mr chair um Representatives Ellison
and Miler both brought up some fantastic
points uh representative Ellison spoke
to how much more simplified this form is
and with 18 questions instead of a 100
that's already going to reduce the
burden and as representative Miler said
we already have more students who are
encouraged because as they're taking the
SAT as part of their Statewide
assessment they see how competitive they
will be at the college level or perhaps
uh see that they might um look to get
some secondary education and the trades
with that we're already priming them to
think about that higher education and
we've already reduced the burden well we
haven't the feds have already reduced
the burden by going to a much more
simplified form instead of adding this
burden to these districts why don't we
see how this new simplified system works
before we try and add more layers and
more mandates that the town will have to
pay
for okay thank you and say any more and
I think we should move on to uh part two
and with that I'll turn it over
representative
cores I just wanted to say under B it
says the waiver could be signed by the
parent or guardian or if applicable the
student so if a student is 18 they could
sign that themselves couldn't they
saying that they don't want to do it yes
okay so if it was getting close to
graduation and their parents hadn't
signed it and I think most kids
graduating from high school are 18 they
can just sign the
waiver now but I know my granddaughter
was only 17 I was I was 17 99% of
students today are 18 years old when
they graduate from high school so that's
all
okay thank you um
I guess my uh thought on part one here
is more fundamental in that um I don't
agree with uh um having this as a a
requirement uh for graduation that they
either have to fill out the uh
application or file a
waiver
um I I object to to that uh
component
hson uh
yeah I don't I just wanted to share
something that um I noticed as a school
board member um when uh kids are
graduating in their high school they
used to put up all these little tags
about where they're going to go to
college and it never occurred to me
until I actually saw it as a as the
parent of a senior that there are some
kids who opt not to go to college and uh
you know might might want to work in
their our family business and it it
really made me think about how it made
them feel as uh students maybe that you
know who who's celebrating them and I
just wanted to add that to the
conversation that BL on should wrap it
up okay thank you Mr chair um I I
actually was 17 when I graduated college
and if you look at the ages sorry do you
want to mute
sorry um if you look at the ages um with
the compulsory education if you are six
by September 30th then you go into first
grade that means that kids born in June
May June July August and September won't
be 18 if you have this form in by May to
make sure that you're on track for
graduation while that allows about 60%
of the students to sign their own waiver
that leaves 40% of the students out out
in the
fold okay with that I think we spent a
lot of time on that so at this point
I'll turn it over to
uh representative Vlad to take over part
two yeah thank you very much uh um I'm
sorry I'm a little bit late I was across
uh with represent cordelli uh talking
with the speaker um so evidently you've
gone through the first part of 147 uh I
have some issues with that as well um on
the first part um I I believe that that
um I I I'm in the same ballpark as
represent cordelli is that I do not
believe that we should this requirement
for graduation even though you may be
able to get a waiver but that still
requires you to get a waiver uh however
I do believe the FAA is very very
important and uh that we need to have
kids filling this thing out I think it's
a responsibility of the guidance
counselors to ensure that there there's
in-person communication with parents and
and and students and to provide
assistance in completing the FAFSA uh I
don't think we need to be tracking how
many uh fafsas are filed that is done by
the national clearing house uh however I
do think that it we need to have
something in place where we do say the
number and percentage of graduating high
school students and parents provide um
are provided inperson School assistance
in completing the free application for
federal uh application or student aid I
think that uh there there is a place for
that but I do not believe that this bill
in part one does it the way that I can
support thank
you so that's the my two cents to it uh
so let's move on to part
two part two is relative to the central
registry in the Department of Education
to maintain records of found reports of
abuse and neglect are there any comments
on this
section represent
Miler good morning good morning uh
representative lad the one question I
guess I have on this one is
um I did get a
contact of a concern
and this dealt with um bus drivers who
are not the regular bus yellow bus
drivers uh these are would be bus
drivers who I would consider more uh
coach drivers um ones that would uh take
uh kids uh students on a longer trip for
example down to Washington
DC uh with which you know you usually on
those trips you you've got the teachers
You've Got U uh chaperon from parents
Etc and the the issue for me on this
it's a question um should those drivers
of those kinds of what I would call
coaches fall under the same
guidance as this particular registry is
looking
for
um the individual that contacted me said
many of these uh companies
do this more as a it's not an an ongoing
kind of a thing it's not a daily thing
it's not even a monthly thing but it's a
special event kind of a thing and the
concern is is that if they have to go
under the same kind of
scrutiny as this particular law uh
proposal mentions they may stop doing
that and so it's I'm not sure anybody
else has had that kind of a contact or
that kind of a concern
but it was raised to me and I think it
is a legitimate concern particularly
when you think that these kinds of rides
that would be in these specialized
coaches do have other parents there uh
do have other adults there that are
supervising the students in this
particular uh Journey that they were
taking on this bus that so that was the
one question I think Rick that came to
my mind and I hadn't frankly even
thought of it until it was brought to my
attention well thank you Mel um we did
have some some discussion or at least it
was alluded to when this bill was
presented and I I tend to agree that we
have on trips that going using your
example to Washington DC on their annual
trip they may use do in the in the
junior high school level there's always
a supervising credential teacher on
board the bus or a uh representative of
the school on the bus that is an
employee and so and these are coaches
I'm talking the coach bus you know the
old trail Trailways or the Greyhound or
the you know the conquered bus that goes
down or the the bus service that goes
from Dartmouth down to Boston um so you
know I I I tend to agree do the bus
drivers then have to have you know the
same same uh uh record check and all as
do the the supervisors that are teachers
on board the
bus I think you raise a question which
is
legit yes represent wood
Woodside thank you uh Mr Woodcock thank
you representative Woodside here thank
you just a question on um as I read part
two distinct from part three part three
I see represented mil is concerned for
uh inter intermate uh coach drivers but
as as I read part two lines 24 and
25 uh school bus drivers and
transportation
monitors I I and I'm probably wrong but
I interpret school bus drivers mean
those that drust the yellow bus that
drive the yellow bus and therefore the
the uh uh ones that representative Miler
and yourself represent are talking about
I think may be more applicable into
section three we're talking about the
the the piece just just a clarification
I'm probably wrong that's a good point
it's a good point Steve yeah
yeah okay are there further hands up to
discuss this represent Porter you're
here I I am here Mr chair thank you for
welcoming me um I I guess although I've
read the bill through I'm a bit confused
part two is dealing with
um reports of abuse and neglect is that
referring only to
employees of a school district or are we
talking about parental abuse and neglect
in this section
mean would a school be rep having would
the Department of Education be having
records of verified abuse and neglect by
parents I think I think this one is
primarily focused on on School Employees
yes licensed employees
licensure yes but part to just seemed to
be I was confused by the langage of the
Bill thank you for clarifying for
me are there further questions or
comments on part
two my sense is that the intent excuse
me Rick but I think the intent here is
uh I mean we've had situations where an
individual who may have been dismissed
uh from a uh School District because of
inappropriate behavior and then gets
hired in another school district it
seems to me that this register this
registry is an attempt to try to
catalog uh those who have abused uh
children students Etc so that there is
some kind of a registry there that a
school district can check to see if an
individual has in fact had a similar
kind of experience in another school
district that was dismissed the the one
thing we don't want to have happen is to
have abusers just get shuttled to
another school district and perhaps have
the same kind of experience so I think
this registry is an attempt to try to
provide some kind of a
centralization of those who have had a
history of this kind of behavior so that
they will not be able to be employed in
other in other school
districts that's my understanding of the
intent of this
language and and that that would be my
intent or understanding too of what the
intent would be I can recall when I was
in a school administrator out in
Alaska there was an individual that had
abused uh students that moved from one
Community into
Anchorage and was hired in Anchorage and
then did the same abuse and Anchorage
that should should have been stopped
earlier either with loss of credentials
loss certification but it wasn't uh I
believe this part of this part two of
147 does set up a h a registry which I I
believe that type of incident could be
caught and and uh hopefully we'd stop
you know uh a Perpetual abuser from
moving from one Turf to another Turf um
so so I I you know the I don't really
have an issue with the part two I didn't
do any corrections within it I thought
it read pretty well I thought it was
something we needed um the issue of the
bus driver I think that that you know
that's correct it says bus
drivers and transportation monitors I'm
Transportation monitors a little bit
more slippery for me but I think part
three may may help us out with
this
uh good morning
[Music]
who's get my computer working Mr chair
it's representative Mullen if I might
make a comment and ask a question yes go
ahead representative Mullen okay so my
comment is that uh stripping this down
to the simplest language uh embedded in
the verbiage what I see is that we would
that what this bill would do is create a
registry that would prevent somebody who
was founded of child abuse from being
credentialed as a teacher in New
Hampshire I mean period re that that's
that's how I read the bill which you
know it begs the question who would want
somebody who was founded of child abuse
to be a credential teacher in New
Hampshire anyhow um but my question to
you is this um if Diana Fenton is
available to answer questions on this
bill would it be Poss possible for us to
bring her forward into the
conversation do we have her she's she's
in here I can her can you get me as a
person that I can't look at that oh okay
yeah um okay I've just promoted Diana
Fenton welcome to
education okay um Miss Fenton is in the
meeting
someone have a question uh represent
Mullen did you have a question I did I
wanted to know uh from attorney Fenton
whether or not I was being overly
simplistic and missing anything by just
saying that I think that the uh intent
and the language of the bill establishes
a registry that would keep track of
people that were actually found guilty
of abuse and prevent them from being
credentialed as
teachers or
that requires a license good morning
committee members um thank you for
having me representative Mullen in my
experience working with you uh you are
never overly simplistic um and you never
miss anything so um what what part two
of Senate Bill 147 does is in its
simplest form it will grant the
Department of Education before the
Department issues a credential to a
firsttime teaching applicant it will
grant the department
access to the already established DCF
central registry to address rep mullen's
point if someone has already been
founded for abuse and neglect uh
allegations we would not want to offer
an Avenue of access to Children through
the Department of Education this is
something that employment school
districts they do not have access to
this but the department would have
access to it when we credential people
to teach to address representative
Myer's concern of having individuals go
from one District to another um if
they've been inappropriate with a child
at one District we don't want them going
to another District that is a function
the department already does through its
um credentialing system and through the
code of conduct which this body passed
back in uh
2017 through House Bill 210 um under the
code of
conduct has to report a violation of the
code of conduct to credentialing at the
department of Ed and that is how the
department can take action on the
license which does exactly what
representative Miler stated which is
preventing an educator from going from
District to District Senate Bill 147 is
really just strengthening the
Department's credential when we issue a
credential to an individual it really
says to the field this person has been
cleared through the dcyf central
registry they don't have a finding of
abuse and neglect and uh through a
different legislative um Bill we're
going to also do a criminal history
record check and so that tells the field
this person this individual is
employable and based on these checks
safe around
children thank you thank you I'm happy
to take any other additional questions
thank you for your interest in this
bill
yes go ahead
repres thank you Mr chair uh I keep
looking at the section I read it again
and again in most of the section is
simply listing jobs or or occupations or
or fields of people that need to be uh
subject to bankr checks to include
social workers and media Specialists and
as we said bus drivers uh why are
coaches or assistant coaches not in this
mix if everybody else is I don't know if
anybody can answer that
but uh I'm happy to answer that question
representative Moffet and and thank you
for the question and the
opportunity um coaches are not always
certified
Educators so if you think about it as a
ven diagram a certified educator can be
a coach but a coach doesn't have to be a
certified educator I am not a certified
educator but I can go and uh work with
my local School District to be a coach
for my son's you know soccer team or
what have you coaches are um
regulated via employment they are not
certified by the
department that helps thank you thank
you but that that begs the the question
then um I've got the code of ethics
right in front of me here and um I can
remember when we put this together but
it's for those it's for certified folks
um many of our coaches are non-certified
but they're also there during school
hours at times and certainly from 3
o'clock to six o'clock or on weekends
with kids um so when we're hiring an
individual uh that's not certified how
does the school then ensure that that
individual's not had a prior history of
abuse
so RSA 189 colon
13-a does the criminal history record
check for employment so if I work as a
coach at a school district I would be
subject to that statute and I would have
my fingerprints checked and my criminal
history record checked um this is where
we get into the difference between
employment and
lure and that's what Senate Bill 147
does 147 gives the Department of
Education access to the central registry
to um check that Clearing House your
question representative lad is can we
grant that access potentially to
employment to districts to check um I
think the answer is yes we could do that
currently they don't have that access
but we can't do that in this you we can
work on doing that in the future and I
would look forward to working with you
on that I think this Senate Bill 147 is
an important step forward because right
now uh districts and the Department of
Education we do not have access to the
dcyf central registry and uh we are
recognizing the importance of having
access to
that thank you very much uh Miss Fenton
and uh represent mfet that's something
you might want to note that you brought
up the question the co-curricular
activity and non-certified coaches uh we
may want to look into that uh a little
bit deeper in terms of uh future
legislation and I'd be happy to work
with anyone on those ideas um we are
always looking at new ways to strengthen
child safety so I'm happy to serve as a
resource on that thank you Diane uh
represent Woodcock your hands up yes sir
thank you represent lad jne Fenton just
a question clarification this uh DCF
central registry that that we taking uh
the information from now does that
include out of state
candidates or is this strictly for a New
Hampshire candidates for lure or those
pieces so it would only be if you
applying to the New Hampshire Department
of Ed to get a New Hampshire teaching
credential we would then run your name
through the New Hampshire DCF registry
so it doesn't matter if you're from
Massachusetts Vermont or New Hampshire
if you're applying for a New Hampshire
license we would work with New Hampshire
DCF however I think I know where you're
going with your question representative
Woodcock so I will take an opportunity
to do a little bit of a plug for work
we're doing At Doe we are currently in
the process of creating anou with the
state of Massachusetts to grant us
access to the
Massachusetts it's DCF it's not DCF but
it's the same fundamental thing um grant
us access to their records to run a name
through their database as well and we're
we are hoping in the future to expand
that to all our New England sister
States we're we're not quite there yet
but we are working with Massachusetts on
that thank you attorney Fenton thank you
representative L let asked a question uh
you're welcome uh for Miss Fenton um I
can recall when I was uh an
administrator in Alaska we hired
teachers from all over this country
country Idaho from Maine a lot from
Maine some from New Hampshire mostly
along the Northern Tier and there was a
check is there such a thing as a
national register where if you're
applying for certification I.E like in
New Hampshire and you come from Idaho is
there any way you have the uh ability to
check H for the background and and see
what has gone on in in their previous
life there is the federal background
check the FBI check that is what is
accounted for um in 18913a that's the
employment piece and as I mentioned
previously the Department of Education
will have the ability and the authority
to do a criminal background check
federal and state um when someone
applies to be a firsttime teaching
applicant I think the other part of your
question representative lad
is is there kind of a a national
Department of Education database and and
there is it's called NASDAQ it sounds
like the stock market version but it's
um it's not quite it is a private
organization and can um pay membership
to track educators and uh enter
Educators into this database uh New
Hampshire and the New Hampshire
Department of Education is a member of
that
organization so we do receive
information from other states and we
enter um Educators who have had their
license Ed or suspended uh for
violations of the code of conduct we
enter them into that system as well to
prevent them from going to other
states so as a followup does uh your
department your uh certification folks
over there uh check with the NASDAQ not
the stocks but with that
organization
um just as you were asking that question
I want to just double check with
credentialing before I answer that I
believe that that we do but um I know
that that is an initiative we're
undertaking so let me put a pin in that
for a moment and I will check and get
back to you on that I do know we
remember and I know we have access to
it further questions uh Miss
fanton thank you very much
Diane thank you OPP are there other
questions or discussion points with
reference uh part two here of
not have a hand ra by Mr applebe in the
attendees
[Music]
list okay yeah if Mr applebe is there
let's um Mr applebe could you raise your
hand
again thank
you that's from the Department of
Education for those that don't know Mr
education again Mr
applebe
you're there did you have a
question good morning and um thank you
for promoting me uh I just wanted to
answer the last question posed to
attorney Fenton regarding the nasc list
um that list is uh we connect to their
database electronically from our lure
database and um each night overnight a
job is run that compares any new
applicants in our que to the National
list and those are flagged for the
Bureau of credentialing for the next
morning and that happens daily so um if
if in fact an educator action is taken
against their license in another state
we are notified of that you know within
a day and um if that individual were to
apply here then we would refer the
matter to our investigator before
credentialing that
individual
are there questions for Mr
applebe I have one um might as well get
them all out uh if you have an
individual that's coming in from South
Carolina and went through and had the
check when they initially got their
certification in South
Carolina however there have been any
issues that that person had been
involved when subsequently to receiving
South Carolina certification and the
individual then decided well I'm coming
up to New Hampshire to be a teacher here
um when you're checking with this the
the NASDAQ I is there is that updated as
situations occur during the tenure of a
teacher yes thank you for the question
chair um the a as a state if a state
takes action against a license or other
credential of an educator in any of the
50 states States as well as several
territories um that in that one of the
steps that all the states follow is they
then report to nasc that that uh action
that was taken a revocation a suspension
a reprimand and that is loaded into the
database as it's occurring and then um
at that point you know we're made aware
if that person then applies here so if a
person receives a reprimand but doesn't
have certification strip
um you will see that when you do the
check yes and again we would then turn
over that to our investigator who would
check into the
situation thank you are there other
questions for Mr
applebe not seeing any thank you very
much Steve thank
you any other questions or discussion on
part
two Let's uh move on on to part three of
of
147 this is relative to transportation
of pupils in a contract
carrier champ yes representative bone
yes uh this is probably what
representative mil was talking about
before and I I have to agree with him
um thing is on any of these buses
whether it be even you know on long
trips or even Sports there's always
adults teachers coaches and other
chaperons on the bus and this may
also if somebody's a convicted pedophile
they have to
notify their employer of that and they
won't be allowed to carry so I don't I
think this goes overboard and I don't
think it's needed because there are
always some adults chaperon and what or
coaches on buses that uh coaches on on
coaches will say that are being used by
the school districts to go places um
other than the big yellow the big
yellows we know they're they're covered
but I don't think this goes a little bit
too far um like um represented Miler had
said before we might not be able to get
a coach to take people
anywhere if they have to go through all
this extra expense so I don't think part
three is needed
yeah represent Woodcock you have your
hand up yes sir thank you chairman I
this is just an open question I have two
questions uh I'm looking at uh obviously
pot part three but I'm looking at the
section um that deals uh I'm on page
four and I'm looking at the lines two
and three I had highlighted from the
before um where it said job training
programs I'm not sure there would be a
monitor or a teacher uh in that bus with
them to a job training program and also
under special education transition
Services um maybe representative Cornell
lolan can clarify that for me I'm
thinking transition services are from as
they exit out of the special ed program
to uh the 2122 so that may if I'm
correct I'm not sure that may not be uh
one that has a staff person as well
those are my two questions represent Ed
thank
you are there any uh responses to
represent
Woodcock other than the fact that uh
yeah I mean a transition service for a
specialed student typically applies
to uh a Ser an internship a supervised
apprenticeship something that's aimed at
the end of their educational experience
to transition them into the world of
work right so um that would I I I would
I suppose it would depend upon the
nature of the disability but ostensibly
yes you could I would think have a
18yearold on in a van going to a job
site without an
adult I don't think I ever heard of them
sending them off without an adult though
I because I I know in Manchester the
high schools have staff that that's
their job to accompany them to their
their job site so I I I would hope that
they wouldn't send them by themselves
does does that if I may Mr chairman does
that also include representative Cornell
Mullen does that include the 18 to 22
year old transition as
well before we yeah I I would think it
would the you know the IEP is in effect
until the 21st birthday so um I would I
would think it could be some individuals
between 18 and 21 okay so the other part
of
the job the job training program is not
necessarily monitored in terms of uh if
they have Coach
drivers I don't yeah I don't think I
don't think that there's an easy way to
answer that question because you know
it's an individualized ed plans so every
student's going to be different right
but the job the job if I may represent
lad the job training program is
separated from the special ed by by
commas so it's a separate entity it'd be
internships externships for the general
School population I'm not sure they
would have a staff person with them they
would just be providing Transportation
so there does cause some reservation
there in my mind thank you
representative
Leed uh yeah Erica uh thank you Mr chair
um I I feel a little lost here the part
three talks about um contract carriers
to transport 16 or more passengers and I
I don't quite understand how we'd be
transporting one or two student special
specialed education students to a job
training on a vehicle designed for 16 or
more passengers without any sort of
chaon
okay representative
Miler thank you thank you m thank you Mr
chair I think the other qualifier here
that's important where it says that
required to travel at least 75
miles that to me is is a fairly high
threshold for traveling and I I don't
know perhaps member of the committee
could answer the question are there
particularly dealing with the special ed
transition I mean 75 miles is a pretty
good distance uh and it's it's not like
going you know from
cirage to conquered for example I mean
it's uh it's significant and I think
that's a that's another qualifier that I
think U uh provides uh some detail in
this particular
Bill thank you and just to follow up to
that you know I can remember the
discussion with the director from Keen
that is it 75 miles one way or is it 75
miles combined to 150 miles we didn't
have any uh response on that so the
mileage figure may be something we want
to fur the look
at rep
Celli my question was answer thank you
okay um representative lad just
clarification I I have in my and I may
be wrong Rick but I have my not I have
my notes that I asked that question at
the hearing and the answer was one way
75 miles one way so that would support
representative Mila's it's a big trip
it's not the in town so yeah I can
remember that uh represent Woodcock
that's why I was I'm suggesting that we
have it say 150 miles round trip
okay thank another way of saying it yep
absolutely
likeus can't hear you yeah I know I had
to unmute
um my qu I going back to what uh R Miler
said in the beginning that third part of
this says
as well as school bus driver cert
certification requirements and so once
again it sounds like this applies
to you know a a coach trip down to New
York City or whatever um or Washington
DC so and certainly those guys don't
need to have school bus driver
certification so how are we going to
exclude them
yeah it does speak to school bus drivers
in the last part of the
build would we just be able to eliminate
um all the
other um situations and just have it
be I mean eliminate that field trip one
and so that's the other
organizations is that making
sense yeah I I think field trips are
definitely uh something we want to
protect we don't want these companies to
get to stop doing the field trips so if
we took field trips out and left all the
other things in perhaps that would just
cover the problem do we want to say
field trips using a professional coach
server you know somehow make that
different than a school bus field trip
or
whatever this clarification or question
fiur might include trips from here to
Boston or Museum of Science so you hate
to have that out of
there
right I think it's more
can we put in
instead um something that they don't
have to have the school bus driver
certificate as long as there
are I don't know somehow qualified other
adults like teachers or whatever
teachers or
[Music]
parents I mean
somehow we wanted to allow those Co
those professional Coach Services to be
able to do
this but field trips is kind of uh more
generic anybody have any answers for
that
one I'm just represent line I'm just
concerned because it says shall include
we're not limited to so this is just an
expansive list so no matter what we put
in to take out I mean it's just a wide
open list so I I think we're probably
not gonna make much Headway just taking
out one or playing with it because it
says not limited to so they a school
district could you know do their own
other additional
pieces well it's the school bus driver
certificate that I'm concerned about for
say a conquered Trailways
driver well I would think that if we're
going to use a commercial bus such as
you speak
of
that there would be if you're talking
special education students there
certainly is going to have to be
somebody a school supervisor certified
person on the bus with them um if you're
talking about regular students as well
uh so where would we be using a
commercial bus if we didn't have a a
certified person on the bus I can see
the exception maybe a coach that even
the kids school that my kids go to they
use a commercial bus to take the kids to
sporting events seeing that they cannot
they have to travel a long way they're
in a division where there's no schools
close to them so the maybe the nearest
one is going to be over in Burlington or
down at Brattleboro from St Johnsbury
but they they need those buses for the
room for the athletic gear they need it
for the uh bathroom facility on the bus
and there's a coach there who may not
have
certification but he this coach is a
School
employee so so so really we've been
talking about three categories there
either certified Personnel a parent or a
School employee which would cover Rick
what you just said as far as a coach who
may not be a certified Personnel but as
an employee and a representative of the
district yeah I don't know about the
parent uh but the the uh certainly the
coach is an employee if the parent's not
being paid yeah what kind of training if
they had they may have had it may not
have or background search
represent Bo yeah I was on a long field
trip and uh when I was in school and the
parents Al we had to be fingerprinted
and a background check for the field
trips that went over a day so for
example to Washington DC and whatnot if
there was a parent I did one going to
Europe I had to be fingerprinted and
background check so all the parents had
to also so for those long trips you know
for day trips not but for trips
overnight they had to
be don't Volunteers in schools have to
be think be background checked
anyway if you're volunteering at your
child's school that's one of the
requirements do we have any uh
superintendant or do we have anybody
that's a director of transportation from
a department on the attendee list it
might be able to help us out with some
of the answ Jerry F Rick Jerry FW is on
the list whether oh Jerry F is there
yeah I
see I'm promoting you to panelist are
you
available he is
available thank you thank you I was kind
of
multitasking chairman so could you just
kind of rephrase the well we're we're
talking about the part three of 147
Senate Bill 147 which addresses uh the
use of contract carriers which are those
Greyhound type buses that have the
bathroom Etc and when we have kids that
are going on a trip that's using one of
those carriers do schools have any
requirements or is there any statutory
requirement that I don't know of where
you have to have a certified person or
an employee of a school on the bus
beside the
driver thank you for that question um it
would be my experience and I think the
experience that there are
typically uh teachers on those buses and
all volunteers to school uh trips need
to be uh need to have passed uh criminal
background
checks and and so your coach who's not a
teacher and doesn't have certification
but is an
employee that there's background check
that's been down in that employee as
well correct that would typically be my
experience I can't say it's 100% for all
trips but in any of those Washington DC
trips that I've been aware of and
involved in over the 40 plus years in
this business there's always a certified
teacher on or more than one actually on
those big charter
buses okay um thank you very much Jerry
are there any questions for Jerry
F re Mullen your hand I I don't actually
know whether or not this question would
be for uh Mr FW or not um but it has to
do with uh the fact that the bus drivers
are supposed to comply with
26329 RSA
26329 also in Roman numeral 3 after the
criminal back ground check it says as
well as school bus driver certificate
requirements so I I I'm reading that as
you've got to take the
test that a bus driver would take to get
a bus driver's
certificate is anybody else reading it
that
way Alicia
is right I mean it says that you have to
do everything that a somebody who was
driving a school bus would have to do
and that would mean taking the bus
driver's exam right because it says all
the requirements within that and the
school bus driver certificate right and
so that's how can we how can we ask that
of uh you know conquer Co con Coach
Lines right
right
okay are there further Is there further
discussion on this bill or further
question can I just have a followup Mr
uh Mr lad yes goad lad I just want to um
again in that section three um with
regards to the criminal background
checks for volunteers at school there
are different designated uh types of
volunteers at schools and uh some of
those designated types would requ ire
fingerprinting some would require
fingerprinting and a background check it
depends upon the responsibility of the
volunteer and whether or not they're
going to be alone with children um I
know that the chances that a conquered
coach bus driver is going to be alone on
a bus for 75 miles with a student is nil
but um I I do think we you know before
we make any assumptions about that
background check we ought to seek
clarification from uh maybe the doe on
it
okay that we can yes L yeah can I sort
of add on to Sue's question on this and
and um and just a a couple questions
about the criminal uh background check
uh is does that also include
multi-state um and I know that's this is
beyond the scope of of you know part
three here and does it also include
include the um what we just talked about
in part two the abuse and neglect um in
the um in the
registry is there anybody from the
commercial uh DM or DMB we actually yeah
we actually have DM
Elizabeth so hopefully she's available
I'm G to you panel we have uh Elizabeth
lei uh listening she's from the dmbb as
a director uh maybe she can help uh with
some of these
questions good morning can you hear me
okay yes we can you good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Elizabeth B I am
the director of The Division of Motor
Vehicles um and thank you for allowing
me to speak I do want to let you know
that we were taking a neutral position
on this part of the bill but we were
working really closely with Senator Khan
on providing him the Lang language to
really lead to the policy decisions that
he wanted to achieve and I know that he
was working very closely with I believe
this Keen school district and kind of
leading him in in drafting this bill um
his goal was to really ensure that the
drivers that would be utilized for the
motor coaches really mirrored the
requirements that the school bus drivers
have to uh complete as well so I think
that's why you're seeing the language
that you are seeing because he wanted to
ensure that they are the drivers meet
the same requirements as those that are
required of the school bus
drivers are there uh any questions or
further discussion with the
director that that does clarify some of
the history here so Elizabeth you're
you're saying then that the driver of
this uh conquered coach is going to have
to have that also have that same school
bus driver certificate as required 263
col
29 that is correct yes the bill intended
to ensure that this the coach drivers
would have to meet the certification
requirements and would have to have a
school bus certificate in order to be
utilized for the school related
activities do okay now another question
for you Elizabeth then is this going to
be really restricting
uh the availability of commercial
transportation um thank you for the
question I really am not sure if I'm in
a position to be able to answer that
because I'm not sure whether the motor
coach companies would be willing or
would be in a position to uh put their
drivers through that in order to
contract with school districts um to uh
drive for the school related activities
or trips so I am not sure whether
they're standing ready and are prepared
to meet meet their requirements I think
it would be better served to ask um a
representative from conquered coach or
another company like
that thank you very much uh
represent go ahead U thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you director bki
this this question may be a bit broad
but given all of the economic challenges
and the difficulties with people getting
to work are you seeing anything through
the DMV about um fewer people looking
for these license is and pursuing these
training requirements and might that be
an additional
hardship um I can tell you that the
school bus industry specifically the
association always struggles to find
school bus drivers uh in general we've
been seeing over the past few years
we've been seeing a decline in CDL
Drivers and and the IND the CDL industry
is having a hard time finding qualified
drivers so I think the the industry um
and Commercial Motor Vehicle drivers are
definitely in hide and demand uh and
they're I know the school bus
Association is always looking and trying
to get to incentivize employees to come
on board as well I hope that answers
your question represent LE you follow
sorry if I can follow up um I guess one
question is if that's a matter of
disqualifying conditions or of training
and if there's um such a demand for it
it it might might it be possible that
the Coach Lines won't will be afraid of
additional competition if they pay for
their their drivers to be scho by
certified thank you for the question but
again I'm not in a position to be able
to answer that question thank
you are there further questions of Miss
belucky
yes represent
Woodcock lad thank you lad thank you for
taking the question is there any uh
reciprocity in terms of the school bus
driver uh testing and the coach Lodge
vehicle testing I mean are they are they
both the same uh DMV
test no there are different uh
endorsements that you have to have on
your license so there would be a
separate passenger endorsement for coach
and there would be a separate School Bus
certificate in order to drive a school
bus thank you very much thank you
chairman Le
sure represent Mullen thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my uh my
question
mine is uh just a practical one in terms
of operating a school bus and operating
a coach bus would it require the same
skill set I know that there are two
separate paper tests but as far as
actually driving the buses if you can
drive a coach can you can you drive a
school bus and vice
versa um I thank you for the question I
can look to see if I can get you more
specific information I can tell you from
a vehicle perspect perspective the
vehicles are different uh there are
different training requirements for
school buses that um that really um
center around of safety of the occupants
on those so there are requirements to
conduct evacuation drills and things
like that there are specific training
requirements of the school bus driver as
well and there are annual training
requirements so um again the I think the
school bus certificate requirements are
a bit more restrictive to ensure that
the safety of the of the kids on the bus
is really um is is really front and
center thank you very
much any further questions reps and
leus yes um to go along with these even
if the local companies coach companies
decided to have a certain number of
their drivers get this test I know if
they're driving very long distance they
may have to trade off drivers I remember
as a band member um going
to to Canada to play for a uh um the
Toronto
Argonauts we had to have a new driver
now you know whether you whether it's
there or crossing state or kids going
down to Florida to play in a
um parade or
whatever the question you know how are
we going to if we pass this
how are we going to have any chance of
having whoever that driver that has to
pick up and drive the next section
because they're only a lot to drive so
many hours at
once how is I mean I can't see that that
would
work thank you I am um again I think the
bus companies would be in a better
position to answer that because if they
drive those distances I assume that they
have procedures in place to be able to
accommodate those because again those
those are as you as you stated those are
not really requirements specific to
school bus drivers but there are more
requirements um related to commercial
Motor Vehicle drivers where they have
limitations on how many hours they can
be behind the wheel um so I'm not sure
what the current process is in place or
procedures um are that are in place for
those Bri drivers and companies that
have those long-term um or long distance
trips Missy I I you have a followup uh
represent likeus well I was just just
wondering how we could possibly since we
have our requirements for school bus
drivers how we could possibly place that
on some driver from another
state relief
driver again um I am not sure if I can
if I can answer that specifically I I
would really reach reach out to a motor
coach company to see how they deal with
situations like that right now I'm not
sure whether they have two drivers kind
of starting out in the state of New
Hampshire and one is driving and one's
kind of resting until it's time to take
over I'm not sure but those those hours
our restrictions are currently in place
for really any Interstate drivers or any
CDL um drivers so I would assume that if
motor coach companies have long trips
like that they must have procedures in
place to ensure that those hours
um um the limitations of those hours are
adhered
to thank you thank you Miss buy have do
you know of or have you heard of a
contract carrier using a vehicle that
does not have a valid state inspection
sticker do I know of that um does that
occur um I am not sure
um how however um I know that um I I
have a member of State Police that's
listening as well so he might be able to
speak to um his experience with that um
so I am not sure if I I I specifically
don't know of any instances where those
vehicles have not been inspected well I
asked that question uh due to the the
bill does State the motor vehicle used
by the contract carrier passengers shall
bear a valid state inspe inspection
sticker I've always assumed that you
know the the buses must be inspected um
if you have an officer that's familiar
with that uh I'd appreciate hearing yeah
sure absolutely and I think I can I can
clarify that and and if we need to he
can also chime in um but commercial
Motor Vehicles specifically Interstate
vehicles that go out of state are not
specifically required to get a New
Hampshire state inspection they are
required to have an annual inspections
that that meets the federal safety
standards and and uh it's a little bit
different it doesn't have to be obtained
within the state of New Hampshire it can
also be obtained outside of the State of
New Hampshire so I think spe this
specifies that this would be subject to
the New Hampshire state inspection as
well is that duplicating then what is
currently being
done um I can tell you that school bus
uh school buses themselves obtain they
have a specific school bus inspection
certificate as
well
but let's say take a CO a conquer coach
for example that they they get the
federal
inspection and they meet that safety
standard then by requiring to have some
kind of a New Hampshire inspection like
we all do for our residential vehicles
our private Vehicles is that going to be
a duplication and an additional cost
which is just another cost and doesn't
and and is trying to comp is the same
thing the sa the federal safety
inspection
is and uh I can get back to you on that
um because again I'm not
sure um I'm not sure of the answer to
the question so uh let me just write it
down and I'll get back to you on that
whether it's going to be a duplicate or
whether one can uh can take place of the
other thank you very much
sure have you heard of any issues where
there have been situations dealing with
the commercial bus drivers that have
been abusive or or caused some rationale
that you know that we don't want them
around
kids uh well I I think it's important to
clarify that currently there are no
Provisions for school districts to be
able to contract with private um motor
coach companies to um to transport kids
for school related
activities um so I think what Senator
Khan is trying to do is provide the
opportunities for schools to be able to
do that and I think that was um that was
why um he he introduced this bill so
currently any transportation related to
school related activities that's
contracted by the school is required to
utilize the yellow school buses and
certified school bus drivers
so oh go ahead I think that I heard a
question there well I I I think I heard
some rumbling too repent B was that you
yeah just a point we know they're doing
it school district are hiring coaches to
go on on Sports trips to Washington DC
to other longdistance trips so I I I
don't understand your your comment there
because school districts are doing
they've been doing it forever so I don't
understand your does statute allow them
to do that
rph so I can tell you that there are
currently no statutory or administrative
Provisions that allow the schools to do
that well and and I think if I may Mr
chairman I think this is the question
that the industry is Raising around this
bill and that based upon what uh Ralph
has just said that they are kind of
doing this as a favor uh to school
districts not
withstanding um what uh Elizabeth is
saying and that if in fact this piece of
legislation were to be enacted that they
would in fact stop doing that as a favor
to school districts and I think that's
their concern yeah right repres Hopson
you have a question I don't have a
question I have H someone from the
attendee list Sergeant Christopher
Kelby I don't know is he with DMV I'm
not
sure okay so can I promote Elizabeth buy
uh would it be fine for you to have your
DMV Sergeant
speak yes absolutely Sergeant Kelby was
actually in charge of Pupil
Transportation so he might be able to
answer some of your questions related to
enforcement or what he's seeing on the
road some of the questions that you had
previously including the inspection
questions as well thank you Elizabeth
then we'll we'll we'll bring our our
Sergeant up so we can
welcome to education subject
Cal you don't thank you you're welcome
sorry I got kicked off of the uh call
can you guys hear me all right yes we
can okay um I I just wanted to reiterate
what director Bley said in regards to uh
current law
uh relative to motor coaches
transporting kids it it's it's not
allowed uh that school School
departments choose to utilize those
resources they're doing so under the law
or outside of the law 26329 and 25996
specifically St State the how how
children are to be transported so I just
wanted to clarify the air that though
there might be schooled uh sius
utilizing motor coaches for the
transportation of children it's illegal
um and more importantly is it puts the
SAU um in in a in a in a serious quandry
when it comes to liability of something
should happen so to to answer the
inspection question uh no there would
not be an incurred cost uh outside of
the uh safety inspection for the vehicle
currently St uh school buses in the
state of New Hampshire um regardless of
size have at a minimum two State safety
inspections done a year one is a state
safety inspection uh and over I think
it's 15,000 pounds uh they're they're
they're actually inspected twice a year
uh and they're also subject to a school
bus safety inspection which is separate
from the state safety inspection and
they're given us a sticker uh indicating
that they passed the school bus safety
inspection so a full-size school bus
would actually be State safety inspected
three times uh a motor coach would fall
under its gen it's its annual inspection
requirement whatever that happens to be
it would not be something that the state
would be imposing under this current
legislation thank you very much Sergeant
are there questions for sergeant
Kelby yes represent
Woodcock thank you the sergeant I'm
assuming or maybe unfortunately you've
been listening to all this dialogue for
the last 40 minutes uh M if you have
been you understand the intent of what
we're trying to do trying to get in a
situation where everyone is legal and
everyone is safe
uh do you have any recommendations on
how that might happen based on what you
heard so I I I can tell you that the
department of safety is is neutral on
this uh I've heard a lot of concern
about putting in uh maybe uh you know um
some kind of hardship on uh motor coach
drivers or companies that are
transporting kids um outside of the uh
you know for for whatever uh trip
currently again just to point out it's
illegal they're not allowed to do this
we're not imposing anything on them
currently we're saying if you want to
transport kids you have to undergo the
background check and the training the
training is 10 hours it's it's not a uh
a real you know you know they can
contract trainers uh there's first aid
training involved with that uh safe and
un you know what what is safe loading H
you know how can the kids be you know
taken off the bus safely I mean it's
important training um again pointing out
that currently if you use you know Joe's
motor coach service down in I don't know
Portsmouth to transport a kid a group of
kids from from Portsmouth to to whever
it's illegal you can't do that unless
under
25996 you submit uh the information to
the department uh for criminal and motor
vehicle background check and and again
pointing pointing out that the
background
check and the training is regulated by
the Department of Safety Division of
State Police Division of Motor Vehicles
we are the ones that that do that the
the Department of Education and the saus
have their own um requirements outside
of these parameters so um I just wanted
to be clear on that followup
representative lad yes you may thank you
sir uh side last question for me andal
thank you uh do the coach vehicles have
rear
exits
you know I I I am I I I try not to to
advertize this because I don't like
getting my hands dirty uh after 23 years
on the job I'm not a big fan of getting
my hands greasy but I am a certified
Federal inspector and um I am actually
motor coach certified and most of the
buses have evacuation windows and then
the the um side entry and that's it um
some depending on the design of the
vehicle
um some of the buses have you know a
variety again it's it's really design
specific um there's so many square
inches of evacuation place that are
space that are needed on a on a motor
coach I know that's not answering your
question but that's as well as I can
answer it well I appreciate you using
the rag and wipe your hands on that
thank you thank
youer uh thank you Mr chair Sergeant we
you know we've acknowledged uh in this
hearing in this work session that in
fact motor coaches are in fact being
used um not withstanding it being quote
illegal um so the question that I have
is that without any kind of
Statute that governs the use of these
motor coaches if there were to be an
accident if there were to be some kind
of a an incident with these motor
coaches with students from a school
district on them what's the liability
here because we have I mean there there
is a history here of these motor coaches
taking athletic teams uh places and
being hit by a semi Tru or whatever what
is the liability of uh without a law
governing this what's the liability of
an
SAU I I really I I could tell you that
would be up to the individual court all
I can tell you is that RSA
296 specifically States
what you need to do to drive a vehicle
if you fall outside of that I don't know
that that falls under court and the
legal system and I'm not I could not
answer
that thank you you're welcome sir thank
you um Reon
leus yes back to the question of
um if we pass legislation allowing
schools to use motor
coaches and they're going a long
distance so they have to trade drivers
potentially more than one time how does
that work if we're requiring New
Hampshire's uh school bus driver
certification so as I read the law um if
you're going to transport students in
New Hampshire you have to submit under
25996 the uh training and background
check which is the roster so we already
know that you're driving for a kid so if
C&J Trailways was going to do a trip
down to DC or something and they're
going to be driving more than I think
it's 14 hours or something like that um
under log book regulations presumably
the uh C&J Trailways would have another
driver um that would be on the bus to do
the switch driving or take the
appropriate time off to utilize another
employee of a new another bus company
outside of the State of New Hampshire we
wouldn't be able to enforce anything
that that you know there's no way for us
to know that but I I don't think it
would be uh realistic for a a motor
coach uh to utilize another driver from
another location another company to
drive um you know on a longdistance trip
much like most motor carriers currently
if they have uh if they're team driving
the the drivers work for the same
service I'm not saying it's not it's not
possible that they could utilize you
know some you know you know Sister
service from another state to do that um
that that would really fall you know
aside from them not not stating staying
within the law as it would be or the
amended
legislation you know again I mean we
can't really just like you guys use
motor coaches now there's one Trooper in
the state of New Hampshire that is 100%
dedicated to people
Transportation one person that's
it so his job is primarily
administrative and investigation of
accidents for him to go out and police
these locations and and I've spoken to
many superintendents many principles
about the uh legality of using motor
coaches you know we try to get it out
there hey don't do this God forbid if
something bad happens you're falling a
file of State New Hampshire law that I
would have presume there would be some
some some liability involved with that
um you know we can only enforce what we
can see presumably um if if if the
amended uh legislation is as it's
proposed goes into effect I would assume
that a motor carrier would be utilizing
for a long trip uh drivers of that same
location or or company to provide that
Transportation well when I when I've
seen that happen it was the same company
but a different state and so that's my
question how are they going to have New
Hampshire state bus
drivers uh
certification if they're being picked up
in another state through the same
company well
so we again presumably it's a school
it's it's a particular
SAU um so we're only
regulating the the the kids being picked
up by New Hampshire um saus so we have a
lot of companies in Massachusetts and
Maine and Vermont actually that provide
transportation services to uh saus and
citizens of the state um while having an
out of-state driver's license and it's
just a matter of them being certified in
the state of New Hampshire it's it's
it's not that hard it's just a matter of
uh you know having an instructor provide
the 10 hours of training again presuming
that the legislation's passed and
presuming that everybody follows the law
it wouldn't be that hard for them to do
that I know first student and uh student
transportation of America have locations
uh Butler's bus service nrt they all
have bus uh bus services outside of
state and they have backup drivers that
that will pick up um you know if if they
have a driver that's out sick uh we we
provide transportation in the state of
New
Hampshire thank you Sergeant ke uh Kelby
um it appears that one of the primary
reasons for this bill coming for forward
was is the legality and liability
issues um we're requiring in this
legislation as I see it about five
things the first four uh that the B the
commercial uh vehicle have a valed state
inspection
sticker and comply with the provisions
of RSA
376 the bus driver hold a valid
CDL and the school bus and a
uh school bus driver certificate defined
by RSA 263 colon
29 this bill we could take care of the
legality and
liability by just uh deleting the part
that says a school bus driver
certificate find in RSA 263 colon
29 um would would that make the buses
any less
safe I'm gonna I would ask the director
to to respond to that um I I don't think
that that I would be the right person to
to respond to that I do want to point
out that um yes that was very politic um
the SBC the school bus certificate and
the CDL uh license the director just
responded she would take the that that
question are two different things so
currently Chris Kelby myself I I possess
a
cdla with a uh tank endorsement a motor
coach endorsement and a school bus
endorsement but I am not allowed to get
behind the wheel and of a yellow school
bus and drive it on a school operation
the school bus certificate is a separate
uh document it's not an endorsement it's
a sec it's a certificate that and and
keep in mind that that we have companies
out there that use Ford focuses as
school buses because they fall under the
law uh they all they need is a driver's
license and an SBC card or School Bus
certificate card and that's the 10
question um exam that they have to take
uh uh I'm sorry the 20 question exam
that they have to take to the DMV uh
with the 10 hours of training so again I
the director did just chime in that she
would answer that question i' I'd rather
just fill myself from that that's okay
okay thanks Sergeant yes sir uh thank
you for the question and representative
I will say again that um that was really
something that Senator Khan intended to
ensure that the provisions that he's
introducing really mirror the school bus
um certificate I know he worked very
closely with a superintendent out of the
um Keen School District I believe but
also with the school bus or School
transportation Association so um again
why while we were helping him draft it
he was really driving the intent and
this was the intent that the drivers
really meet the same requirements on the
motor coaches as they do um for school
bus certificate as
well thank you very
much are there further questions on on
this or discussion on this bill on part
three yes represent Woodcock yeah the
last last comment on this um out of all
the
dialogue the thing that scares me the
most representative lad is the fact that
we just realized that these motor
coaches do not have a safety exit one of
the uh PL me of New Hampshire school
administrator's job was to uh uh
participate in the emergency exiting
practices from school buses which I did
multiple times every year and the and
organizes so the kids come off the back
they they know the orderly procedure the
whole things the fact that we're now
aware beyond the school bus legality
piece of these coach buses that don't
have a rear emergency exit nor do the
student students have they have the
window nor do the students have a chance
to practice that that to me is the
biggest scare that's illuminated by this
whole Bill thank you so then let me ask
you a question then uh representative
whitcock are you saying then you would
prefer not to have us use the commercial
carriers no I'm not saying that because
I don't have a from that my point is
representative lad that I think this
commercial carrier uh we just opened a
huge can of worms and the biggest one is
safety of the students emergency without
practice excelling and I understand the
seu 29 issues um that they brought up
before and and all the school buses the
youngsters in the middle schools go to
the DC I understand all that but this I
did not
recognize the driver is less concerning
me than this I did not recognize that
the safety provision of student exting
and practicing is so limited to a window
in one of those coaches um that that
makes me very very nervous that's all
thank wouldn't this would couldn't we
accomplish that in this bill by
requiring prior to that commercial bus
being used that the CDL D the
driver uh inform the students on the bus
and hopefully the the certified teacher
or coach or employee on that bus here
are the exit points just as you do when
you get on a
airplane uh you're you're you're told
you know we can all go through that
routine uh would be just would that
satisfy rather than saying to the
contract carriers you now have to have
your drivers have this
certificate which we know that there is
a lack of uh qualified folks out there
with CDLs especially with the oil crisis
we have going on right now and we know
with school buses drivers as well I
represent I understand what you're
saying and having them speak you know
the left in the air things will come
down like an airplane all the big exits
my concern is not this the driver saying
the rear window and the far right that
has a signo that's what you crawl out of
my thing is you have to take sixth and
seventh graders in freshman high school
and have them practice it so they can
learn it they not gonna in the case of
emergency they not gonna be able to go
through that everybody going that one
window I think this opens up a huge bag
of worms that's just
me you have your hand up uh thank you Mr
chair I actually one of the conquer
Trailways down to Boston every day for
years and years and years uh there are a
ton of exits in there distributed
throughout the bus I know the students
won't have a chance to open them up and
jump out which would probably be a lot
of fun but they're they're throughout
the bus and and they're really easy to
find with big right big red
handles okay we're practice makes
practice makes perfect you can't do it
by just talking about it not with kids
that's why we coach
teams all right uh not a lot of fun
during an emergency
either okay thank you very much all are
is there any further discussion on on
this
bill I want to thank the yes represent
luno yeah Rick
um uh I you know I I agree with a lot of
what's what's been said uh on here and I
think um you know particularly what
Steve brought up that this is really
uncovered
I think a um a liability issue that
every school district across the state
um uh probably would face and you know
12 years on a school board I had no idea
that that um that this was um uh uh not
uh not was was basically an illegal
activity uh for the schools and so now
we've all heard this and um and the
department representative has also heard
this um
and and I think there's there's clearly
complexities here um but but I think
there's two parts that we need to do um
or that we should consider is is um
relieving the LI at least District
liability so that they can at least
continue to um you know have the ninth
grade field trip to Washington and not
ride a big yellow bus you know for that
and uh and secondly try to try to come
to some um U good um
um try to put together some good statute
that that is um
um that is enforcable that is realistic
and and I think even some of the things
you suggested Rick make a lot of sense
um maybe as a starting point but but I
don't know if we're going to be able to
solve this one completely today so um
but it's clearly something that needs to
be
addressed thank you yeah there are two
parts there Dave um one is the legality
and the liability that that can be
easily dealt with I think just by the
part uh under number one Roman one um
that that can occur um the other issue
is the safety issues which represent
Woodcock brings up and and the training
um that is a little bit more complex and
ter are
resolving uh
so I I don't know we may have time if
somebody wants to craft some language uh
to you know to try to address that but
uh I don't think we're going to be able
to do it I concur that
quickly further further
discussion on this one I want to yes
represent like this yeah so what do
people think if two changes on looking
looking at um in part one where it says
a valid state inspection stier if we
included
or whatever the name of the federal
inspection sticker that um a lot of the
bus you know the coaches would have to
have whatever that's called so that they
either had a state one or that Federal
one which says they've been inspected
and everything um and then the other
thing would be what if we uh
um took out the school bus driver's
certificate left all the rest but took
that particular piece out as a
requirement because then schools could
go on doing what they've been doing
which is sending kids to DC on those
coach buses which they've been doing all
along and that way they they are
covered and having the other
requirements you know most of them it
makes sense anyways it just to me
doesn't make sense that they would have
to have the school driver's certificate
especially if they're having to trade
drivers in in doing that uh Alicia you'd
have to also look at Roman
three uh which again looks at the uh bus
driver certificate requirements what I
was talking about ran three the school
bus driver certificate requirement just
take that out and in Roman one
add or that Federal inspection sticker
whatever that is I I would have to find
out but instead of just a valid state
inspection
sticker what would people think about if
we just modified those two things well
you'd also have to take out in Roman one
the reference to RSA 263 col 29 it's in
two places in that
bill oh I see
yeah y so okay take it out of both of
those places so Rick I I think that I
think what what Alicia is suggesting um
makes makes some sense in terms of a
stop Gap um but but I think we we
absolutely need to make some make some
progress on on the rest of it um as well
and um and you know to to uh to assure
that that
um you know that the kids are safe
during an emergency and I don't know
what the answer is on on those I don't
know if you want to um add I mean we can
study it this fall um and and actually
hear from you know the the
representatives of the commercial car
commercial lines and um and Department
of Safety and DMV and and um Department
of Ed and put that works there there's
there's several tacks in doing this um
one I think we can take care of
immediately the legality and liability
issue that can be done through modifying
the first section that represent leus
was looking at uh in in Roman one the
issue of of the safety on the bus is
that also related to maybe having uh
somebody an employee also on the bus or
somebody that's a teacher on on the bus
that is you know is able to U work with
kids and maintain the decorum the safety
that you normally have on a school bus
when on a field trip um uh so you know
in the short run possibly you know we
can correct the one area um it's
possible that we could also then come
back with legislation to clean up the
rest of it uh in the second year of this
bium
yeah yeah absolutely agree with you Rick
um something is better than something
has to be done nothing is not an option
well the the legality has to be yeah
yeah yeah so so perhaps what we could do
is have a couple folks get together here
and try to come up with some language
which might be you know the intermediate
step here and then following through
with those considerations dealing with
the safety issue
and the proper training on supervision
on the bus yeah the elephant on the
table has to be addressed representative
lad that's the key
issue well I see the key issue is the
liability and legality and that's a huge
issue for a district
right yeah it is it is it is huge
representative but I'm not sure it is as
huge as 20 kids stuck on a bus emergency
and can't get out so I think I think
both both pieces have to be done but
there I just say the elephants on the
table is out with public we need to
address it if someone
does right but current current statute
addresses neither of those right so
anything we do is going to be better
than what there is right now
right Reon Hopson yeah may I let
Sergeant Kelby
and the meeting we oh yeah we yeah yes
uh for sergeant Kelby and Elizabeth
deluy thank you very much for listening
to this um is there anybody here on our
committee that be interested in Alicia
you you were there you with part of this
are are you willing to try to work with
others or or develop something yourself
which would address you know step one
and step two is is a a bigger picture I
think right and and we might even be
able to put some one line in this one
that just requires that um the bus
driver goes over
safety you know the safety instructions
or whatever before you the bus pulls out
well I think it's also important that
there be some kind of a teacher
certification on that bus or an employee
of the school district on the bus I
don't know of any schools that hire
conquered coaches or whatever coach that
don't put other adults on I mean I've
never heard of them doing
that I I
concur so I think the more important
thing is just to make those coaches
legal and if we can right now just put a
oneliner in about covering the different
safety on the bus and
then go in detail hopefully Stephen
you're willing to go into detail and
come up with a law for next year to add
to this well I I'd be happy to work on
that um on behalf of the committee I
would suggest if we require students to
practice exiting school buses through
emergency exits that we need to have
perhaps practice on any vehicle they're
going to be on in the coach that's to
the general question representa leas I'd
be happy to work on this with you or
whoever represent L put on it good okay
how about if we set up a working group
of represent Woodcock and and representa
leus to try to address
what we've gone over today is that good
with
you she back by
no I think we need to address this
legality liability issue immediately
right yeah so you could look at Roman
one there and you could put a period
right after CDL commercial driver's
license period and then uh look at three
and maybe you delete three so you'd have
you know Roman 1 and Roman two uh that's
just my quick fast look but there there
may be some other you know things that
you two could come up and make a
recommendation to us later on next
week next
year okay okay Alicia that's fine with
me okay you two get together set up
Steve I'll be happy to and I think you
had some really good points I think we
need to figure out how to work them in
yes thank good let's get on now to um
part four of this this bill I want to
thank everybody that was listening and
helped us out with this
today part four is uh a state aid to
special education for certain
communities of a thousand or fewer
residents
um you know I had I had some concern
with this uh let me briefly state that I
I know that we already provide uh
$250,000 um annually for the districts
which are unable to um uh pay for some
of the costs of unexpected emergencies
dealing with the special education Aid
that's the catastrophic Aid the student
that comes in that's the high cost
student they may not have a reserve fund
most districts do have some but it's a
very expensive cost deal we've talked
about it many
times this bill also then goes beyond
and says an additional
$250,000 available for um any Community
or community of a thousand or fewer
residents um so uh with that that that
that total comes up to $500,000 to me
and and there is no definition I found
of the word Community municipality
District yes um not community and I know
we're talking about unincorporated areas
probably most likely and we have several
of them hail's location Hearts
location uh yeah hails yeah haes and
hearts uh so
um you know I understand that
predicament so it's open to discussion
right
now yes
represent
Cornell okay so I thank you for taking
my question chair the lines 29 and 30
the impact of special Le cost when
emergency assistance is necessary to
prevent significant financial harm um
what how do you decide that it's doing
significant financial harm I mean a a
community of a thousand or less may have
one student man Chester has
56 students that using the old term of
catastrophic Aid would qualify so I mean
I think 56 students would make
Manchester eligible for a significant
financial harm I'm just wondering what
What's the de definition of how do you
decide that it's causing the community
of a thousand significant financial harm
as opposed to another Community that's
over 000 that may have many many many
more
students the the that's always been
resolved by the Department of Education
to discern that uh I do not honestly
know the criteria that they use for that
decision making for the current
$250,000 for these
situations
um I know that there are small districts
that do encounter this type of hardship
as does the larger District as
well yes R Celli yes thank you Mr
chairman um um based on some
correspondence with the uh
Department um I believe it is a rule
that outlines applications for
emergency applications for emergency
responsibility and what the document
shall entail um and that U
includes um
unanticipated cost uh financial crisis
they could not be dealt with through um
budgetary line item transfers or other
financial management
techniques um and that there are no
other sources of financial support
available to assist the district so I
think that this uh definitely uh relates
to a small District more so than uh a
larger District who is going to have a
larger budget from which they can uh
draw resources as opposed to the small
District of under a thousand
[Music]
students
yeah that that's in rule right
now uh but as far as making the actual
decision you have to use that criteria
that Glen just read and make a
decision represent
Woodcock represent lad um just two
questions uh Rick if I may can you can
you give me the um um to the the the
last line on line 29 I'm looking at the
pl say when emergency
assistance I don't I don't know how
that's Define I understand uh Patty
talking about catastrophic Aid and Glenn
but I don't I don't understand how that
means emergency assistance is that
that's the first question the second one
just on behalf of Representative Tanner
who's not with us today she'd asked at
the hearing um how does this impact uh
Regional uh uh Co-op school districts I
don't know if we have an answer to
that thank
you okay the um the first part of that
you asked uh emergency assistance of
course in terms of it's emergency
financial assistance our fundings are
assistance basically to mitigate the
impact of special education
costs um you know little permont
received kids two in one year both at
$250,000 approximately fees of course
that's some of that's reimbursable
through the formula but it still went to
the point where they didn't but they had
the wherewithal to take it from other
accounts and other sources that they had
so that would not be necessarily an
emergency funding Assistance or need um
there there must be some districts like
the two I mentioned to begin with at
least one of them
where that does occur um and this other
criteria is that you have a thousand or
fewer
residents well we all know there's some
towns a thousand or less that are B
residents that are very very property
wealthy towns
correct correct yeah you know I can name
a couple Monroe Waterville
Valley
Pont so
um yeah it does
uh just to the the second question
representative L the follow the co-op
the co-op school districts do you ever
do we ever get a good response for that
I I don't have an answer to that one
does anybody here represent Porter I
don't really have an answer I do have a
concern however because here in
Hillsboro we have the Hillsboro Dearing
district and we have little Windsor who
has maybe 400 residents that sends their
children to our school they don't have a
school of their own they do have a
school board and they have a small
budget but they don't have a school of
their own so if a child moves into that
District that cost is absorbed by
Hillsboro Dearing school district and we
also have Washington which does have its
own School up to the fifth grade but
then those children come down to the
hillsb Dearing school and and if if a
speci special needs childood that's
expensive that's something that has to
be taken on by our district although
Hillsboro has you know 7,000 people that
live in it so you know it's a confusing
to me very confusing um situation that
we would be in to get would would we
qualify we do have some reserves for
special weed but certainly not enough if
we had two or three kids move in so just
just a reiterating what people are
saying that's a big concern does it
work meent cordelli thank you uh yes um
further my discussion with the
Department on this um a town that sends
their students uh to another District
that town I.E school district is
responsible for the uh cost of that
student they're sending tuition money to
that Co-op who of the district under a
tuition in agreement um they therefore
would be uh responsible for the extra
cost associated with a special Edge
student who moved into the district such
as representative Porter I think was
making reference to it or I think um
under the um situation that was laid out
by uh the prime sponsor Senator grad um
so that small
District um uh part of a co-op or
tuition agreement would be responsible
for the special ed cost and would have a
difficult time and possibly financial
crisis in dealing with a high cost
student with special
needs repr
Porter I'm not sure how that would work
for Windsor for example would Windsor
apply to the state for this emergency
Aid they don't have a an office they
don't have a school um they use the SAU
for all that so would Windsor be the one
that would apply for that Aid or would
the Hillsboro deing School District be
the one that applied for that Aid seeing
as how the child is a student and
there's no school in
Windsor go ahead um if if Windsor is
paying the educational cost for that
student they would likewise be
responsible for the specialed uh student
um costs um and therefore I I would
imagine um fill out the uh application
for emergency
assistance that is correct for example
we have Benton that's in SAU
23 and Benton does not have schools they
send all their kids to Woodsville but
there was a child there that was a high
cost special ed student and Benton then
went and checked out the cost and they
found it was actually cheaper to send
their that student to another school
district and the costs though were
totally on the Benton taxpayers to do
that um within your Co-op District you
know we have the same thing with with
permont which is part of
sa23 um they they have to cough up all
that that funding in your little town of
you're talking about represent Porter
would have to come up with those dollars
that's why that pot of $250,000 is
available they would
qualify yes so so um thank you Mr chair
along those lines though um I think the
requirement for a district of residents
to be responsible for IEP costs is on
court ordered placements and um and
manifest hardship placements and things
like that I think what what what
representative Porter is talking about
with Windsor as an example also is
specific to the co-op agreement that
that the district has with the member
towns and it could be that they're just
responsible for whatever their Prat a
student share as opposed to specific IEP
costs for each student that that resides
in Windsor or Dearing or or Hillsboro
and um and so uh you know so I I
I I I I think it could be the case as
what you're saying but it doesn't have
to be the case and um and it would be
important to to know this maybe um Miss
Fenton has um has some um clarification
on on Co-op agreements around the state
but what could happen in in the the case
that representative Porter is talking
about if in fact Windsor is not
responsible for every IEP dollar of
every student in res residence in
Windsor they could collect the
$250,000 and um and only have to be
responsible for the um the Prat share as
opposed to the full cost of the
IEP is Diana Fenton there yes she is
would you like me to if she can have any
information on
this thank you Miss
Benton are you
available good good morning uh committee
members thank you for inviting me to
join you I'm going to defer to um
Rebecca fet who's in charge of special
education uh she would probably know
more about this particular section of
the bill than I do in terms of
cooperatives each one has their own
agreement we do have copies of them and
and hopefully this situation would be
addressed in those agreements but um I I
can't speak to them all they're each
individual and they they might not have
addressed this particular situation but
I'm going to see if uh Rebecca fet I see
that her name is popped up and ask that
you promote her and she can better uh
answer this question thank you she's
been promoted welcome to education M
forette morning Rebecca good morning
representative lad thank you for U the
question so as um as Miss Fenton said um
each School District makes a different
agreement between them regarding special
education students so they may have an
agreement where um they pay a certain
rate per pupil and then they also have
an agreement where they pay a certain
rate for special education students or
that cost refer um reverts back to the
district that is sending it so it's
really um local control here um it's
really what has that District determined
in their agreement with the district
they send their students to if they've
agreed that um in some cases the
whatever District they send them to is
going to incur all cost costs for every
kid that they send them to um then that
sending District wouldn't wouldn't incur
any extra cost however typically what
happens is um they will say you're
paying this rate for this student
however if there's a paraprofessional or
an outof District placement you the
district that is sending that student
would then incur that cost um and have
to cover that cost as well as the
tuition cost to the district but it it's
different for district to District um
it's not a it's unfortunately it's not
one blanket answer to say this is how it
goes in every every Cooperative School
District Rebecca the statute States
right now that the state may designate
up to
$250,000 uh for this purpose um have you
had uh school districts or small town
District uh come to requesting support
from that pot of money and is there such
a pot of money so as um I have only been
in my position for a year so I have
reached out to people who have been here
longer than I and um from what I
understand no one has ever asked to
access that pot up until um probably a
year and a half ago we did have one
school district reach out to access that
however none of that money has ever been
set aside um because that money is the
same money that goes to special
education Aid and what typically happens
is we pay special education Aid out of
that first and then if there were more
then it it would have been set aside as
I understand it however we don't
typically pay full on special education
Aid um we did this year but we haven't
since 2008 so typically there isn't that
$250 left over um as I understand it
it's never been set aside ahead of time
so they've never taken that 250 off the
top and then done special education
Aid so there's really never ever been
enough money in a special education cat
catastrophic Aid account and so the
money's been sprinkled over the total
number of kids which qualify for that um
so in order to support this particular
paragraph within statute we just be
sprinkling fewer the same dollar out to
you know more directions uh
it I guess the question is that I have
here is that if you haven't had folks
coming and asking for that
$250,000 um do you know of any
communities that would come and look for
that uh I could see some of the
communities that have to cover the
difference between um what the cap is
and then what we start to cover for
special education Aid I could see some
of them reaching out to say um you know
the cap of $50,000 we really can't
afford that and and then asking to cover
that piece but um the and the one one
incidence that um I've been told of
which I said was about a year and a half
ago they had an unexpected student move
in and they did not have the funds to
cover um a residential placement for the
student so they were asking for funds to
help to cover that because it just was
not in their budget to cover
it other further questions for
Rebecca rep represent cordellia I'm
sorry it's not question
okay if this a comment okay yeah I I
think that that's exactly the situation
that
um this bill uh relates to
and the reason that Senator Bradley uh
brought forward to accommodate that kind
of
situation and I know specifically in our
County um H's location for instance is a
small district has no school and sends
their students to
either tenet or to triberg
Academy and would
be severely uh impacted um if they had
to pay for a special needs child who
needed into the district um with high
cost small community
you know I I got a question for you then
um Glen uh maybe you can help me out
like a hailes location is in an
unincorporated Township right cor right
and and with that the county is the one
County the one that's providing the
funds to support this district for
hail's
location uh no they they are not they
they have their own budget um the County
Commissioners act as the school board
yeah for those unincorporated places um
but they uh they raise their uh they
have their own budgets uh based on
taxing their local residents
okay no hey Rick rep luno thank thanks
very much um I'm I'm looking at the the
Dr um tax rate comparison from fy19
which is the most complete one they've
they've got on their their um the
department website right now and just
looking at hail's location the total
2019 total tax rate was
$418 the total School tax rate well I'll
break it up the State education tax was
$25 and the um and the local school tax
was minus
$215 so their school tax rate is
actually zero um in hail's
location so I I I guess I don't
understand diverting additional State
money um
um where there you know you know you've
got tax rates in Claremont of 40 plus
dollars and here you've got
zero okay yeah I was using Hil location
example I I I have no idea um you know
what situation um prompted this bill or
if there was any specific situation
prompted this bill okay okay thanks very
much yeah we're just using that so it's
not attack in anybody of these you know
the small areas
yeah well I I guess I have one more
question for
Rebecca uh at the
department uh is the
$250,000 that's currently that may be
designated for to mitigate these
impacts uh is that sufficient amount or
should it be increased to
$500,000 uh I don't know if I could
answer that question we haven't had
anybody apply for that besides that one
District um who felt that they you know
if you're if you're looking at
um it's hard to say because it most
people I think would be looking to cover
the gap between um what they have to pay
for the cap and then what we were able
to give them through special education
Aid and so right now our cap is right
around
$56,000 and then um and that's only up
to three times the amount and then up to
10 times the amount um so they could I'm
thinking per person it might be around
$60,000 but it would depend on how many
people apply for that fund and because I
said we've only had one person ever even
consider applying for it I I wouldn't be
able to to determine what you would want
to set that at I
apologize
have two people with hands
raised uh see represent is your hand
up yes it was just a point of
clarification um unincorporated places
um don't have local property taxes
because they don't have a local
government um that's why they're
unincorporated so they the county deals
with everything for them and the taxes
that they pay go to the county that's my
that's my understanding as well right
right so um you know they they don't
have a budget because they don't have a
town they don't have anything to budget
for so if a child moves into one of to
hail's location um that money that
they're collecting goes to this County
or not to the county as the case may be
um and see what I was trying to
determine then where I was going with
that is that then you have a student
move in that is a cat Aid student is the
county the one the the the responsible
agent for paying those
costs good question I would I would
assume they would be yeah but I've never
heard of
[Music]
it all I know is that U Carol County
Commissioners and past delegation has
voted on a budget for hell's location
which is not using County tax
funds for that budget there is a
separate budget um for um that
unincorporated
place that includes all normal items
including cost of financial audits Etc
anding and that sort of thing right
representative Celli the the county
provides the police policing the county
provides takes care of the roads
no uh representative I mean that was my
understanding of how that works I
believe I believe that there is an
agreement with the uh sheriff's
department for
patrols yeah so so Ju Just on the
examples that we've been doing looking
at hail location just as an example they
act they do actually have a municipal
tax rate of
$2.98 so they do have Municipal budget I
don't think it sounds like they're an
unincorporated place um but just above
them on the Dr spreadsheet is Hadley's
purchase and it's zeros going across the
board except for the county tax rate
where they pay a flat $2,000 to the
county for I think exactly what
representative Porter was um um you know
was talking
about H to C if I may represent little
hail's location does pay some cost to
the town of Conway as representative
quelli indicated their primary Police
Service is the sheriff but they do use
Town fire uh and Tom police when
necessary and they also they also
tuition some of their school some of
their students uh to main uh than to New
Hampshire so I don't know if that
impacts DRS the other part that is a
typically over 55 communi so it has very
few if any
children like on the doe website they've
got one one student
yeah okay represent Porter is your hand
still up it is but it should not be okay
alrighty is there any more discussion on
part four of of this
bill sure Rick yeah so where are you
thinking are going with part four well
part
four it it's dealing directly with
catastrophic Aid you know the formula
three and a half times and if we go up
through that formula where it's talking
about that um quite truthfully I'm
intrigued with the The Proposal that's
been put together by the department in
terms of the Actuarial you know the the
the ability to have these
associations where we have insurance
pooling of funds to address the cat Aid
student the special education student
that arrives it gives more I guess uh
reliability and confidence to the
district when they're preparing their
budget with a figure based upon that
premium cost so um and there has been
quite a bit of work done with the
Actuarial firm out in Kansas
uh $100,000 I guess was spent to try and
get a calculator and calculations been
made for various districts it requires
five districts to pull at least a
minimum of five districts to pull
together and it's an optional optional
uh uh form of of supporting this this
real concern we've always addressed cat
Aid so I'm intrigued by it and uh I
think that there's it's been um since
we've last dealt with it further
modified I'm very tempted to add that on
to because it would be Germaine it deals
specifically with this same topic of how
we support the special education child
that has this really uh uh significant
cost so that that's that's where I'm
thinking you know that I have been
thinking about uh placing that right in
here and and uh I think it's just about
ready to go too so so we're um so we the
that's in there as a separate House Bill
what what's happened to that in the
Senate I can't give you the just do you
know Glen where the status of that bill
[Music]
is we can look it up for you right now
Dave yeah yeah I I forgot the bill
number on that but um but I I guess it
was 613 613 right right um I I I would
be I would be hesitant to to move that
into an Omnibus Bill given that it's
already a standalone Bill and will be
you know you know voted on by the Senate
um uh but I think the testimony we heard
specifically to to part four here was
that the um the trunch of the the
existing
250 hasn't been drawn on and um and
maybe the current statute is
sufficient yeah uh 613 did pass the
house it went to the Senate uh it's in
it's in house finance it passed house
finance no it's in house finance excuse
me it's that's where we retained it so
it did come to the floor and received a
positive vote and was sent to the second
committee which is house finance so it
hasn't gone to the Senate then no it
hasn't no it's been retained in uh
Finance even though I did not see a
fiscal note attached to
it repent bone yeah my my suggestion is
this since we've heard the the
250,000 there hasn't been used so we
have money so I think you know for right
now I mean one of the problems we have
with these Omni fields we can't
retain so the only thing we can do I
think is amend out part four because
we're not the money doesn't seem to be
needed we got the 250,000 there which
we' heard isn't being used it'd be nice
if it was a separate bill like we do and
we could have retained it to do study on
it but we can't but we still know my
problem too is we've heard all these
questions what about this town what
about co-ops what about every Co-op
we've known for years every time we deal
with Co-op every Co-op agreement is
different even area Agreements are
different uh so we don't know and you a
thousand a few residents like you
brought up there are a lot of Rich
1,000 resident towns well less
so for right now I don't think part four
is
needed
okay
so I I don't know where I'm going on
this yet I I'm it came to us when you
look at this particular part of the bill
part four it came from the Senate and
all these bills came out of the Senate
either 20 240 or 22-2 or 23 to1 there
was pretty much uh a majority of folks
on that side voting for each one of
these
pars um so they all are related to
education so there there must been some
kind of a rationale why
um this this particular section part
four was put in
here I I am having a difficult time with
it myself
so represent woodcock yeah C thank you
represent clearly the the the intent
already in part four in the RSA gives
250,000 that's to school districts
clearly whoever designated who designed
this these three lines their intent was
to try to assist small towns versus
School District so it's like a it's a
whole separate intent clearly but I I do
hear um representative bone clearly that
they have 250,000 not using now which
they could apply for but this this is
specific to towns versus districts
that's the
difference thank you yep you're
welcome further discussion on this bill
we're docking now the whole thing
147 okay when we when we come to meet
next uh
Thursday uh we're going to have to have
one Amendment for the entire
Bill uh we can't be just amending
amending amending because then they're
going to you know that's not how it
works on Omnibus bills we need to have
uh closure on all four sections so
that's going to have to be done um M
have you had any discussion with your
caucus on
this no we were basically waiting for
the work session we've talked about it
but uh needed to have the work session
to see where we were on that David
yeah so along those along those same
lines Rick um I know this is an Omnibus
Bill but it's just a bill um and and and
and even any one bill can be subject to
multiple amendments at the committee
level and then those amendments get um
squished together and turned into a
committee amendment I mean isn't that
how it
works
uh I
I'm not I I I I know that can
occur you know if we're going to come
forward with numerous amendments for all
these
bills uh we're g to be look and if we're
going to take a action on by the end of
Thursday next we're going to have to
have that amendment number and so we're
going to have to then trip across to
legislative services and try to mesh
everything together I don't know given
the nature of some of the Committees
have bills that have 15 or so uh parts
to them which uh they're in the process
of trying to put together too I don't
know if LSR could uh absorb all this as
we get close to the the final date here
right but if we if we bring if we bring
in a single Amendment people might have
different feelings over I mean it's sort
of like an all or nothing I mean I think
um you know someone might might think
that look let's amend out section four I
mean well that's exactly that's exactly
what this we've got anous
bill that's the nature of the Beast yeah
so someone might might agree with
amending out section four but not agree
with amending out section one and we're
all gonna experience that with hb2
aren't we right right right right but I
mean there could be an amendment that
just deletes section one and there could
be another amendment that talks about
the changes in the coach transport um um
thing you know what what what Alicia and
and Steve are working on and there could
be a third amendment that amends out
section four um and people might vote
differently on those three amendments
and then ultimately what passes as an
amendment gets combined into a single
committee Amendment and I think that
happens that sort of happens you know
maybe Jen can explain how that happens I
don't hey Jen are you hanging around I
am okay are have you been listening this
the latter part of the discussion here
yeah um and it's really um the
committee's prerogative you can bring in
an amendment that amends multiple
sections or you could go and kind of
treat it more like each part is its own
bill which you know it sort of
is in our minds at least um and do it
like representative luno described um
that is what we did in judiciary um yeah
I understand that Jen um when Judiciary
had all the separate amendments done how
did they arrive at the final action did
they have a a combined amendment of all
those amendments and in the one and then
amend the
bill yes um what they did is they voted
they went through all the proposed
amendments the Amendments that
passed came into one motion at the end
so it would be UT to pass with
amendments a b and c and that's the
package that had to be voted on
ultimately um and then we combined and
um
got the committee amendment that
combined those ABC D so you made a a a
motion to approve a b and
c uh and then your final after you've
done all those amendments you made those
motions to part one a and whatever then
at the end of when you're done was there
a motion to ought pass or ought to pass
such and such
bill with a and C or was ab and C
Consolidated into
D in this instance that I'm describing
they adopted all of the Amendments and
we um requested a Consolidated Amendment
after the
fact I think it's ideal to get the
Consolidated Amendment ahead of time if
you have the luxury of doing that but I
know it would take a long time to wait
so you can do it either way so so it's
it's an accepted process then to move
separate amendments and then make a
final motion to um amend the bill ought
to pass with
[Music]
ABC yes Pro provided that those
amendments are all
um um compatible and combined into one
Amendment does legislative Services then
take a b and c and make them D yes
because in the calendar and on the floor
you'll need just the one amendment
number so we would contact exactly
that's exactly how I see it good
yeah okay thank you Jen
okay so I guess we have the option of
doing that way as well Dave
okay I mean I I I think honestly think
on some of these bills there may be um
amendments that that you know different
people are going to feel different ways
about so so I think this is the um I I
think that's a good way uh forward and
I'm not talking about it on a uh you
know Partyline basis but but even on a
on on a bipartisan basis uh people could
feel different ways about different
things and um and certainly um um you
know we feel there may be there may be
amendments that that we want to offer
during the exec um that might not have
made their way into a an upfront a you
know a committee amendment that was done
um prior to the exec session so so so
just to just to
clarify using your example Rick where
you have Amendment a b and
c on this particular ular omous Bill
once those amendments a B and C are
passed then does the uh then does
the legislative Services have to come
back with a A Renewed omnus bill or do
the what they're going to do is they're
going to we're GNA make a motion to
approve 147 for example and we have uh
three uh as amended with might be only a
and
C or it could be a b and c or a B
whatever and then we make that motion
and it would also then what I understand
that the when it gets legislative
Services they be combining a b and c
whatever the ones we approved into one
Amendment
for one 47 so and then the house will
consider that amended
omnimusic that's right according to what
Jen just said and according to what
we've done in the past you don't have to
come back you just have okay is that
your experience representative Porter
yes
y okay so what I'm going to do right now
is that we're about five minutes after
12 here uh or 11:59 on my computer I'd
like to take a little break here i' been
out this chair for a little bit and
visit the washroom but also get
something to eat and then come back and
move on to 148 and
135 um we also have S sp19 we have to
address um s sp19 was the Signum
bill and I don't know we haven't have
you did do
44 yes that you did okay
so we that was one when we did with with
uh the two previous bills at the very
beginning it was 20 and 24 I believe and
19 um and we passed two of those out the
pass but we we were in a mode I was in
the mode to retain 19 at that time since
then
we've seen the Signum Bill our Signum
bill came from this side go to the
Senate it's not been passed by the
Senate's an enrolled bill right now so s
sp19 we it could be taken care of very
quickly
um so so what I'd like to do is take a
break here and come back how long do you
need for lunch everybody well no place
in the house what have to go outside
yeah we got to go outside
45 minutes to an
hour how about because there's there's
nothing served here in the cafeteria
they got to go outside find something to
eat can you do it in 45 minutes or is an
hour better come back at one
o'clock you want
45 said said one
o' bags Rick that's why they make brown
bags you're bring your lunch with
you Mr wood represent Woodcock I got
plastic Brown
Bag sign says no eat okay I'm GNA eat
here anyway you go find something to eat
so we'll come back at one
o'clock thank
you J are
you
we I can mute it right now yeah thank
a
go
afternoon
sue a so did I did you go out and hit a
bucket of balls for L
Su I did
not it's putter
day what you need what you need Sue is
the Dave pel's truth board which is a
putting Tech which is which is a putting
um device that I've been using for years
unfortunately it hasn't helped my
putting at
[Laughter]
all hey Mel the way you fix your putting
is have the pencil with a big eraser
that's true you go back to you go back
to the scorecard that's true my yard is
starting to look like Chucksters I have
a I have a putting mat out there I have
a chunk of astro turf that I can chip my
foam balls off of uh so I I'm thinking
about charging an admission
fee you're really getting into this
thing s that's is good this is what the
pandemic has done to me I cannot wait to
be outside always well you know what I
do is you know as you know I walk the
golf course I don't ride in the golf
cart except unless I've got a guess but
you know I'm always reminded of will
rogers's quote that golf is a good walk
spoiled
no
kidding but I view golf it's kind of
like it's instead of going to the gym I
go walking so that's what I do
exactly you make several stops along the
way in your walk Bel yeah yeah exactly
well you know if if you walk 18 holes
you figure it's about five miles right
yeah so it's that's you're walking
straight well that's that's assuming
you're going straight so me I'm
more like eight miles 10 for me
yeah me I just walk around my garden
well that does it too hauling down
hauling down Bittersweet Vines and all
of that kind of stuff hey Elise you got
a pencil there yes I do
603 356
356 290 4
2904 that's my landline my my cell phone
doesn't work at the
house I just I I just told Rick I've got
to get off at three o'clock because uh
we're celebrating the
50th golden anniversary of the 18yearold
vote and I played a a Prem a premier
role in that when I was in Washington DC
in 1967
so the the New Hampshire Civics
organization has pulled together thing
to celebrate that and both renie and I
plus some of my older colleagues that
were there with me are gonna be on too
so it should be kind of fun you gonna be
in costume Mel you gonna be dressing up
as 18-y old no this is this is this is
the costume if you can believe it this
shirt I'm wearing now is a shirt I wore
10 years ago when I did an interview for
U the 40th
anniversary good luck have I still have
some uh Old Hippie beads I can loan you
if you want
M I'm hoping we down by three as well so
I have a trustees meeting did you see
them
yeah I don't who's talking was on me see
I have now so I like going out and
walking down to my bees and sitting with
them well good for you those bees we
need to go have those bees out there at
least that's uh no that's okay folks can
everybody hear
us I've just been informed by Ralph that
he's here so we can
start that's
important that's right important
component there okay so we will go ahead
uh I understand that you gotta be out of
your mail by three o'clock
so yeah but I mean others might want to
be there I just I just have to get out
I'm with you Mel three o'clock yeah me
too chitchat to a
minimum keep all the Chit Chat down
according to De but uh where'd you get
that 10y old shirt Mel my gosh you know
longevity to it well the thing is you
know when when you've got like 50 golf
shirts you don't have to wear them every
day so it's I've never met a golf shirt
I haven't liked
so he only uses it once a decade Rick
it's not one
out yeah yeah yeah some things are just
made
forever so let's go on you better open
my my U video
here jeez okay so uh the first bill
we're going to do this afternoon is SB
148 that is another Omnibus Bill it has
five
parts uh the first part of that bill is
The Vocational
Rehabilitation uh encour
education
um yeah no just Vocational
Rehabilitation and C see let's see what
is it Vocational
Rehabilitation any discussion on part
one yes Mr chair I have my hand up if I
could all right
representa um one of the pleasures that
I've had Being A legislature legislator
is uh chairing the New Hampshire
Commission on deafness and hearing us
for a number of years and so when I and
my co-chair was D Clanton who is in
charge of
um this the locational Rehabilitation um
section of the doe he's also a member of
the de Community um and I know that that
Community is really underserved um the
state compared to other states doesn't
do for its de citizens what other states
do so when I was looking over this bill
before we met this morning and I saw
that there was a section repealed and I
saw that the first section was RSA 200
C7 which had to do with telec
communication equipment I looked up the
section and sure enough it has to do
with with um assistant in
telecommunications and other assistance
to people who are DEA are heart of
hearing and I was concerned I don't know
enough about I wasn't here for your
hearing so I don't know what was um
discussed but I was just wondering if
had been anybody here from that
commission to talk about this deletion
or if that commission had been um
consulted at all with this um repeal
about this
repeal uh represent Porter I also went
and looked up all these sections and I
saw the same thing and it it really has
a lot of impact in the classroom uh so
uh do we have anybody uh Deb that's uh
from doe
here
relax I'll put my hand down so you don't
catch me
again Mr Apple be or I'm not sure
what I don't see
anybody okay's raise your hands well
let's let's
bring me Natasha
lupiani she raised her hand she works
with okay bring Natasha up then thank
you Natasha coming to
education thank you
Natasha are you there Nat
Natasha
still sometimes when you promote someone
it disconnects them and it takes a while
to get back on can you hear me now yes
we can Natasha so I'm actually take
covering for Diana Fenton right now
she's um at an appointment so I'm taking
the notes for her so your question was
for do do we have somebody over there
Natasha At Doe that can help us out with
this Vocational Rehabilitation portion
of SB
148 we're seeing in the first area
that's been deleted uh relative to
telecommunications equipment and that
right in the classroom um we want we'd
like to know why that's being deleted if
it's being placed elsewhere that's fine
but
um we we just uh need further
clarification so if you give me just a
minute I will see if I can get Lisa hats
from V
rehab okay hopefully answer some of
those
questions I do you know that put back in
under
um under Roman numeral
two it says procedures for the purchase
maintenance and repair of special
Communications equipment I'm not sure
why they rearranged it like they did
but well from what I the way I read it
it looks like these Provisions are taken
out of Law and and given the authority
to uh for these sections is given to Ru
making in the doe so it's taking away
from uh us the ability to regulate these
things and giving it to the department
and so that would if I'm reading what
you said representative leus
correctly um that's
where section lines 14 and through 19
come in on page two right I'm just not
sure why they did
that I tried to reach representative
Pearson who is now the current chair of
that commission um but I haven't been
able to reach him
no
one I'm trying to get Lisa I don't know
if she'll be able to hop on immediately
so I don't know if you want to move on
to the next part and come back to
this okay the the next part in this bill
uh is dealing with c technical education
uh it's a different area
um so is is she not in the building
[Music]
or she's gonna sign on in just a minute
okay thank
[Music]
you
this is Mark Pearson calling me now so
I'm G to take
his we have a Lisa
hat person we wanted to bring
okay thank
you welcome Lisa thank you for joining
education good afternoon thank you thank
you for having me how can I help you
okay Lisa this represent lad uh in the
education committee um we are looking at
a Senate bill now that came over has
five different parts in it the first
part part one deals with Vocational
Rehabilitation and within Senate Bill
148 part
one certain uh statutory references to
um telecommunications
equipment um write down through relative
Administration administering the uh tele
communic ation equipment program and it
appears to put uh the rul making for
vocational rehabilitation services in
the part two of this bill uh we like
just know uh why uh for example why the
elimination of RSA 200
C7 relative to telecommunications
equipment that's the first part that's
been deleted yeah yeah um thank you for
the question representative lad and for
the committee uh so this uh
interestingly when our um when our
statute had been updated in the past
this was moved to the governor's
Commission on disability this particular
program um the Telecommunications
program and it actually has its own set
of administrative rules with the
governor's Commission on disability um
so it was just not eliminated from our
statute when it was
moved okay where was that statute moved
to then um I let me just look in my
email I may have a
reference um if I can't find the
reference immediately I will certainly
um ask Chuck uh seya for that um find it
for you
guys let me just see if I might have it
close at
hand
I'm not seeing it real quick but I I
will be able to get it for you um fairly
shortly representative lad okay then in
looking at underneath that particular
statute there's number of other areas uh
within that same uh section of Law
chapter of law that are also being
deleted are they all going to another
location under the governor's
commission no so the um personal
services care worker program um we're
not actually sure where that landed um
it it as long as I've been around which
is about 18 years um that has not been a
part of our current program and we
reached out to um the governor's
commission as well as health and human
services department and they had no
record of it either so this um I'm not
sure how how to address that and I
actually we talked about that um you
know when we were preparing this is you
know should that question come up it's
it's tough because it just seemed to
kind of
disappear wow
uis is Art got his stand up somewhere
yeah art Ellison uh thank you Mr
chairman uh hi Lisa hi art not good to
connect with you I I I have a sort of a
similar uh question about uh c1113 which
is repealing it's this says relative to
insufficient funds I guess I my question
is what is the impact of that on and
where you know yeah what's the impact of
repealing that going to be on the
program okay let me um just bring up the
language I apologize that I was not on
the committee meeting to address these
issues
um right
[Music]
away okay there's only one Senator
that's a prime sponsor on this bill too
that Senator Ward so obviously it's
something that came over from
doe as yeah or something such as that
representative
Porter thank you Mr chair I did just get
a phone call from repr resentative
Pearson he knew nothing about this
change um this is the first that he
heard of it um so I'm just concerned I
don't
know why if it was put in and was
covered under the um commission for
disab Disabilities why the uh Commission
on Defence and hearing loss wouldn't
have been aware of that number one and
number two why then the Department of
Education still has rulemaking authority
over eligibility for um equipment
or deaf and heart of hearing
people it I'm I'm just feeling very
nervous about
this I think a number of us have
questions regarding what's going on here
represent likeus yeah going through this
kind of trying to follow the take this
out put this in and whatever it looks
like the only real change that's
happened is that they got rid of the
procedures for dis urement of monies
from the program established under RSA
C7 and that it took changed in and the
it had had one two and three and they
redid it so it now has one and two and
one and two were the old two and
three um but it's done in a really weird
way but that seems to be the end
result
uh is there somebody still there from
the
Department yeah I'm I'm still here
representative um obviously this
committee has some concerns on this
we've heard the bill uh I don't know if
I heard at that time specific rationale
for some of the deletion of these these
items here are moving
around um what we'll need to have is
that
it's you know without some good
reasoning I think it's going to be very
difficult to go anywhere with this bill
um unless we get something back from doe
saying it's clean up and it's over here
or there or it's being handled by not
the commission for disability somebody
else what whatever might be going on um
but I I feel like a little bit in the
dark
here I understand representative lad and
I will um work on specific um rationale
for each each area of the voke rehab
piece um today and try and get that back
to you
today that'd be wonderful if you
um we're g to be here online for you
know at least to three o'clock right Mel
um and um if you can get anything by
then would you just you know uh you know
join in or put your hand up as an
attendee and we'll pull you back in yes
yeah and I will also um representative
Ellison I'll also respond to your uh the
question around the insufficent
insufficient funding section as well so
um I'll I'll try and get all my ducks in
a row by three thank you very much all
right talk to you soon bye
bye represent Woodcock you got your hand
up still well no I I I was going back to
my notes representative all all my notes
have for that is the bill was developed
by Doe and at the hearing they said was
administrative changes only there was no
depth to the testimony exactly what I
have too and that's the confusion we you
know need a little bit more than
that thank you you're welcome uh part
two uh this section of uh of uh this
bill is relative to uh Career and
Technical
education um I I have a few areas which
I've made some changes on would you like
me to go through these areas first yes
okay
um Jo going down uh uh let's see I let
me get the same format you have out
there okay um I in on the first part of
this bill uh I really don't have
anything beyond on what they have in
terms of expansion or replacement that
that's all fine um I do though have uh
under let's see number three I'm dealing
with a different format you guys are
um it's a place where it says cerent
technical education
consistent of consistent quality shall
be equally available to students of
across the state um where is that
um page three number two May number two
number three I'm sorry number
three that's a transportation cost that'
be the next area but I just have a
sentence in working with Eric farth
where I add in New Hampshire students
are incouraged to access Career and
Technical education to learn and apply
technical academ mic and employability
skills needed for career and life that
was just an opening prefix just before
we get to the section says Career and
Technical education
Transportation this is an area which has
some major changes in
it I'm going to read it to you as I have
right here so go to the section of Bill
that deals with
Transportation can everybody find
that I think that's on page three
yeah okay so what it starts off the
Department of Education is authorized to
reimburse okay I'll read that sentence
the Department of Education is
authorized to reimburse from its regular
budget the full cost fulls in the Bill
of transportation and working with um
Dave Waters um subject to availability
of
funding has been added in for a regional
Career and Technical education students
who attend Regional Career and Technical
Education Centers and for B at RIS
students who attend alternative
education programs located at Regional
Career and Technical Education Center or
other Comprehensive High School
transportation cost shall not exceed the
rate adopted pursuant to RSA 541a by the
state board next sentence there are some
changes here instead of the sending
District it's the students resident
District the students resident District
we're getting at the issue of NASA exor
and Manchester the students resident
District shall be responsible for
providing
transportation and paying the
transportation costs and shall then be
reimbursed from State
funds then a new sentence is added
here if a student is permitted to self
transport the students resident District
shall shall reimburse the student in
accordance with rules adopted pursuant
to RSA
541a and shall then be reimbursed from
State funds what that sentence does it
takes what's in education rule already
and that's happening in high schools
where you may have one or two kids who
want to go to the CTE Center in the
afternoon rather than taking a bus they
may drive their own vehicle
if they're going to a location which is
not in the same high school that they
are you know a resident
student the state reimburses those kids
right now 25 cents per uh per mile it
goes to the school then to the through
the individual that's in rule right now
but the rule in law right now doesn't
have any statutory reference and so what
we're trying to do is get statutory
reference some kids are going to the CTE
Center not going and for example I'll
use mine for example it's in Bradford
Vermont after they finish school at 3
o'clock or 3:30 they can and go to on
the job of apprentice ship type programs
right there in Bradford they don't go
home they go home by way of their own
vehicle rather than having a bus come
pick them up at a separate time when all
the buses go out this is being done
throughout uh the
state so what we're trying to do is
account for how we can provide
transportation services in Manchester or
exor or nashwa where the center is on
the oppos opposite side of the city but
the kids still have to be transported in
a safe manner the school district gets
no Transportation reimbursement right
now for that because they're not the
sending District they're the resident
District so this would allow all
districts to be supported with this now
the cost this is somebody's going to say
what about the cost for this right now
we spend the the amount of money which
school districts re um uh reimbursed for
transportation services back in 2020 was
$680,000
for the state the actual cost for
transportation was
$2.6
Million so we're basically $2 million
short on on even paying the actual costs
right now what this bill would do it
would put into print in the statute
saying that all are going to be
receiving this money not depends upon
what is put in the budget by Finance I
know there's an effort right now to
consider on the Senate side additional
dollars that they can find that Revenue
to support transportation of kids to CTE
they're looking for that $2
million so that takes through that that
yes so I just want to be clear in my
head Manchester will start now getting
reimbursed like transporting students
from West High School to the School of
Technology and back it would be so it
based upon the effective date of this
part of the legislation okay yeah thank
you and the the career techn education
directors when we tried to do this when
I was on the advisory Council for CTE
they were not supportive of it simply
because we're taking that P of pot of
money and now spreading across more
students so
um any questions on on on that principle
or so you have that you have that
language written Rick that you could
send it to us so we could look at it yes
I will in fact for this part of the bill
I'll send it all to you because I've
gone through all this with uh Eric
forworth at the department and gone
through it with the Senators that put
forth this
legislation they I I do have a I do have
a question at the at the beginning it's
more a procedural question the uh under
part
21b where it talks about private schools
and homeschool
students the the question that I have is
that let's say I have a u uh a student
from hopkington who is going to Proctor
Academy and is a resident student at
Proctor
Academy but wants to take a part of a
CTE program at conquered High School
what is the
transportation for that student come
from I'm I'm
assuming that the trans Transportation
will come from Hopkinton High
School not from Proctor
Academy to get that student to the CTE
program am I correct in that I'm just
again it's a proceed I'm not I'm not
debating the merits of stud of a private
school or home school I'm really
concerned about making sure that that
the school district doesn't have to
change their transportation system
to get students from the resident High
School to the CTE program am I correct
in assuming
that I wouldn't assume anything now um I
I for example just take it I'm assuming
that the homeschool
student still has to come to the high
school and not be picked up at their
home to be taken to the CTA CTE Center
other's I I think that's fair to say yes
because I I I don't want the school
district to have to set up special
programs for students who may not be in
that high school as they go from the
high school to the CTE Center or as as
Glenn just mentioned they could self
transport they could do that they could
yeah so I think what we need to do is uh
on the private school transportation I
we need to call Dave Waters or Eric far
worth is he is Eric on the the line here
on
this I don't see his name on here as
attendee is anybody from the Department
there I see Steve
appas yes I'm gonna reach out to Eric
right now to have him join okay so if we
could have Eric that'd be
great he is what else okay
would you like me to
remove no leave Nat on we'll get Eric
too here he is there he is are you there
Eric
y good afternoon I decided to listen in
and as I listened in it said hey we need
to go find
Eric exactly right Eric um in the we're
part two of the SB 148 right now dealing
with Career Technical education the
changes we've worked on um we have if a
student attends a charter public school
private school or is homeschooled
transportation for the private school
kid uh what happens if they're like the
example is given by representa Myer at
Proctor Academy and they um want to go
elsewhere to conquered Regional or
conquered CTE Center who pays for the uh
the transportation is it the the the
academy or is it hopkington or who so
historically um from our understanding
the private schools or the charter
schools have always provided
transportation for the kids who've
attended CTE centers uh if the the
students are able to get to their
traditional sending High School the
public high school in time to catch the
bus they could do it in that way if the
Student Self
transports can work with their home
school district for the reimbursement of
the 25 cents per mile but it would be
calculated from the public high school
to the CTE Center not from whatever
charter school or uh private school
they're attending um so there's there's
really never been anything C you know
really clearly written about it um and I
would imagine because so few students
have ever participated from those groups
and we're trying to recruit more from
those groups right yeah
yeah yeah Eric Eric is representing Myer
my only my my concern is I have no
problem with the private school or hes
school students going there I just want
to make sure that special
Arrangements don't have to be made by
the school district to either pick up a
homeschooler at home right or a private
school in this instance at Proctor
Academy uh that would be an additional
burden on the school district as far as
Transportation goes that's that's that
was my concern no understood and and the
way uh the transportation reimbursement
rules are written the state reimburses
the school districts for transportation
from the home High School to the CTE
Center and it doesn't allow for sort of
roundabout stops thank you very much
sure rules any other we have more
questions for you Eric don't go I'm not
going anywhere I represent Porter thank
you Mr chair and this is again another
ignorant question because I don't know
you feeled very well under the current
law or under this bill as it stands who
pays the tuition to the um Career and
Technical education center for the
private school student or the home
school student or the charter school
student there it it would it's a great
question and not an ignorant one at all
very few people know the answer to this
uh the state pays up to 75% of the
tuition and the student resident
homeschool
District pays the remaining 25% plus uh
so regardless of where their private
school is or Charter School is if they
physically live in Bow and they attend
the CTE Center then the city of the B
school district will receive that
bill 20 25% 25% Eric Eric could you go
through that please I don't think many
people understand the 7525 and that
Transportation coming out
first yeah uh so uh currently there is
$9 million set aside in the education
trust fund uh for tuition and
transportation for CTE
reimbursement uh and through the through
the rules the to the transportation
portion is paid first and right now that
is reimbursed at 10 cents per mile per
kid if it is done on a public school bus
or 25 cents per mile if the student is
given permission to self transport uh as
part of this legislation we are actually
asking for that transportation to be
changed to actual cost for the school
district because they are losing uh
upwards of 1.5 million in transportation
costs uh regardless whichever way this
happens once the transportation is paid
for there is a pot of money left to
cover
tuition uh it is then uh we take the
number of students that are from sending
school districts divided into that pot
of money and that determines how much
the reimbursement cost is per student
and that is what is sent to the CTE
center for the number of students that
are on um uh some from sending
schools uh and the it is up to 75%
that's always the goal uh we never quite
make it there uh but initially a school
district will receive a bill for 25% of
the tuition and then once all of the
state funds are expended if that didn't
cover the
75% the sending school districts will
receive a supplemental Bill to cover
that last
difference any questions on that folks
the transportation I mentioned earlier
to them I took the figures she gave us
from
2020 where the the actual the reimbursed
amount was $680,000
and the actual cost was much more it was
almost $2 million more yeah 2.6 is what
I said um so there is a huge difference
there of about a couple million dollars
now if we expand this to include exitor
NASA and
Manchester um we're going to either have
to put put more bucks into that in that
that you know the 9 million or else
districts are going to get less money
for transport you know for the whole
it's gonna be spread out more ways
correct and I agree and
uh the so the transportation was short
about two million from fully funding it
and the tuition was short about three
million from fully funding it so uh
overall the 9 million was phenomenal
start but if we were to reimburse all of
the schools pay all the schools 75% and
fully fund
Transportation at last year's student
numbers uh the account was $5 million
short uh and I can tell you that this
year coming up although we're we're
excited about it from this end is um our
most of our CTE centers are over
enrolled the applications went through
the
roof um an example I can tell you is
Hudson School District which which this
year has 85 students from sending
schools accepted 200 sending school
students for this coming
year uh and most of our other school
districts are reporting something very
similar and they're now actually having
to do lotteries to determine which kids
can come into CTE because they receive
more applications than they have
seats that's a real
problem so I think the the the uh
legislation that's put forward is uh a
step forward uh we've got to get Finance
to agree with us um in the Senate you
know I've spoken with folks in the
Senate side and if they can find
additional dollars somewhere I've asked
that it be directed in in this area we
are really hurting in for technical
education but gaining students and our
students uh when you take the
achievement scores those kids in
CTE just equate either at or above the
level of those that don't go to
CTE so um we're missing something here
uh represent
Porter I'd like to get back thank you Mr
chair I'd like to get back to what
representative Miler said earlier about
um and the example that he used was a
student that was going to Proctor
Academy and wanted to go to a CTE and
who would pay for the transportation but
also who pays the tuition to the CTE and
I just looked up the cost of a private
school tuition at Proctor Academy is
$59,000 a year so is the state picking
up
75% of the tuition cost for a student
going to Proctor
Academy and the school district is
taking the other 25% is that how this
works oh there this the status covering
75% of the CTE tuition so each of the
CTE centers identify the cost of the CTE
education uh at their CTE center it's
based on the uh average cost of
educating the student in that at that
high school is where the C so that is
the 75% that they're covering not of the
private school of the just the the 90
minutes per day that they're at the CTE
Center so the private school student
basically does gets that that the state
pays for that for everybody not just not
just private not just public school kids
correct any anybody coming from a school
that is not their home school uh for
example conquered has a CTE Center so if
a student attends conquered High School
no money changes hands but if a student
attends any other High School in the
region and goes to conquered for CTE
right the state covers that piece to
reimburse conquered for educating the
child
thank you
sure and the cost for tuition at all
these CTE centers all 20 plus is
different from
Senator drastically different very much
you know thousands of dollars
difference okay
um represent mil thank you repr as long
as we got you here Eric I'm interested
in I'm interested in what you said about
the the uh volume of people coming this
year and having to do somewhat of a
lottery what has the advisory
Council uh concluded as a result of that
and how might they what are they
recommending as far as
expanding the CTA centers to accommodate
uh the renewed interest in this program
so sure it um it it just literally just
came up in this past month's meeting
because the applications for the CTE
centers were all due in March so this
was very new information honestly the
CTE centers expected lower numbers and
they expected lower numbers because of
the Corona virus pandemic nobody was
touring CTE centers so they didn't
expect this but because of it all of the
centers created virtual tours so what we
believe is more students were actually
able to tour T virtually tour CTE
centers then were able to in the past
and suddenly discovered it was available
to them and so this was a extremely
unexpected
turnaround um we had already been
talking about options and it it came
from the study that uh the Consultants
did around Equitable access and looking
for other options and several of our
centers have started uh what we're
calling CTE after dark which is offering
additional CTE courses starting at 2:30
in the afternoon
and it allows students um most
traditionally from the host High School
to utilize the seats afternoon and that
opens up seats in the daytime for more
sending school students to come in uh so
there's um two or three of our centers
that had been experimenting with it in
past years and will be expanding it for
this coming year uh but on top of that
we are U actively open for other options
uh we are looking at the the
opportunities of potentially expanding
CTE into non CTE
centers um VX is offering for the first
time a 100% online cyber security CTE
program starting in
September uh and so we'll be continue to
look at other options uh so
representative Milo we're we're open to
ideas and support from anybody of other
places and other ways we can expand
CTE uh without substantial costs so you
know we're not going to be able to open
an auto program at every high school but
we might be able to expand some of the
business programs or technology programs
into comprehensive high schools that
don't require specialized
equipment thank
you are you gonna be with us a little
bit further here Eric uh I can stay as
long as you need okay good um just so
the folks out there and and uh not with
us here uh we know that the tuition at
Rochester is
$3,100 we know that in Berlin the
tuition is
$7,300 um so there's big big differences
between Center to Center uh as we move
down through this uh particular bill
there's one area that uh I had a
question regarding myself even after
working with you on this um I get to the
page here uh there's a section where we
deleted the fact that um
that in this section qualified means the
project accepts students from sending
schools that's been
deleted um can you explain to me why
that we're
no why uh in this section qualified
means the project accepts students
wouldn't it accept students from sending
districts
schools so yes so um there were some
editing errors on our end and how we
were interpreting it we wanted to leave
that line in the reason we had
originally requested to take to take out
that U receiving from sending school is
because several of our CTE centers don't
have designated sending schools
Portsmith is an example of that and so
the way we were reading the legislation
was because Portsmouth doesn't have any
sending schools they wouldn't be
eligible for the renovation
funds um however when the commissioner
read our notes he said well if a student
from do requested to go to Portsmouth
wouldn't Portsmouth accept them because
they have a program that do didn't offer
and I said yes he said well then they
are willing to accept receiving students
so we had asked to to no longer remove
that line from uh from the bill oh good
because I did I did put it back in in my
copy just it looked crazy to me yes no
we did so it was absolutely just however
people were reading at the
interpretation uh we didn't want
Portsmouth or North Conway or St be
Plymouth to miss out on the renovation
funds because they didn't have sending
schools uh but all of our schools are
officially receiving schools because a
student can attend any CTE Center if the
one near them doesn't have the program
that they're interested in or it's full
or let's say that they are a conquered
student but they're going to a private
school close cler to Plymouth they could
attend the Plymouth CTE Center instead
of the conquered one so okay so yes
please put it back in okay well in in my
copy it's in it's up to the committee
but we'll give it a shot um thank you
and the other other area that uh I've
changed a little bit you in one section
you're talking about stem stem courses
Career and Technical education courses
is in bold then after that stem Capital
STM science technology engineering
mathematics and STEM related courses
that are fundamental and necessary for
success in postsecondary education
career pathway opportunities and the
meet
um when I was uh on the com council with
Steve rothenberger and you and rest of
them um we we had talked about Steve
always talked about the necessity to
have communication skills the kids have
the opportunity to take a writing class
um just as much as it is to take
something in the area of technology so
we are trying to um open it up to more
than just stem to those other
communication skills which are so
important for those going into these
skilled areas is that agree with what
you're thinking as well Eric uh AB uh I
think at the at the extreme end
absolutely what what this piece was uh
if I if I I'm correct is this is the um
accessibility to the scholarships for
the dual enrollment or the running start
classes correct that's correct yes so th
this was trying to um provide a little
more Equity at the CTE centers because
we offer say business programs and
marketing programs which those students
are enrolled in the running start and
dual enrollment courses but because
they're not STEM related those students
weren't eligible but the kid next door
taking an engineering CTE program
received the scholarship for the dual
enrollment program so uh this was uh
Senator uh Waters had asked if we could
edit this bill to include CTE programs
on the broad scale of being eligible
for uh the dual enrollment
scholarship so those are some of those
are the basic changes we've added grades
10 11 and 12 that was there in this bill
uh as we done it for the high schools
wanted for a career tech tech headed as
well so is there are there any questions
on this part from
committee real important part of this
bill I I this my favorite part of the
bill
CTE okay well Eric wait a minute there
rep Woodcock yeah and than last thought
for Eric but it's about this part of the
bill it was dealing back with uh the
full cost of Transportation that you
brought up before I had a question so I
don't know if you want to wait on it no
let's go ahead and ask the question okay
um if I recall what you said that you'd
added it to a full cost of
Transportation subject to funding yeah
so if it's subject it seems to me like
that that that's it doesn't work it's
either full cost or based on how the
state has done historically with things
subject to funding negates the full
cost so we put subject to funding in
there it kills it
I I this change was made by when Dave
was talking with Senator Waters was
talking with me we understand Finance
it's always going to be a
struggle uh to get full funding we can't
get it in just about anything we do from
special ed to CTE to regor regor Ed um
so I I'm I'm not bound subject to
availability of funding but uh I'm sure
that's what the finance people are going
to end up
doing okay just seems to me like it's
sort of like a throwing up a throwing up
a Hail Mary here you know we don't agree
on it okay thank you it's a a fluty pass
for sure but um let's hope that we can
get the
funding uh it's absolutely
necessary you know in a school I I we
have up there they're limiting the
number of kids can go based upon the
money they receive for
transportation and they only have so
many slots that's kind of
ridiculous but it's reality
too Corell represent
Cornell on um well on my page six um
lines 10 through 13 about the guidance
counselors doing career interest
assessments is there going to be some
kind of guidelin Statewide about that or
will that be up to you know every school
just to decide how they want to do it or
was there any thought to that Eric
you're still there I'm so so thanks uh
the the guidance that uh the department
of Ed will be putting out will be around
uh the definition of a career ready
credential uh but the uh the use of a
career assessment tool and the advising
that the school counselors provide is a
local individual decision uh at the
department we are providing a way to as
a career assessment tool for any school
district that's interested in using it
uh but uh that that comes down to a
local control decision okay thank you
sure further questions of the
department not seeing any hands uh thank
you very much Eric have a good
afternoon thank you all again for all
your support have a great
day is there anything else on part three
or part two what where are we on
it's getting
old okay ready to move on to part three
yeah good repad Orman lad is it okay I
remove yes yes thank
you okay part three is requiring
emergency action plans for sports
related injuries
I uh right on the first line I had a
problem uh my problem is that I'd like
to see it read requiring emergency
action plans for co-curricular related
injuries and
emergencies we don't say sports here we
say co-curricular all through statute we
deal with that in terms of Athletics we
deal with that in terms of theater we
deal that with anything that's
co-curricular
and there's a definition for
co-curricular and the definition which
is in statute right now I'll read it to
you uh co-curricular shall include those
activities which are designed to
supplement and enrich regular academic
programs to study provide opportunities
for Social Development and encourage
participation in clubs Athletics
performing groups and service to school
and Community I've also added in I'd
like to put a definition including infam
murals
so um the the sports program we have is
basically
nhiaa and that's high school and
possibly the eighth grade if you have a
small school where you combine your top
level middle school kids with high
school kids to make that division level
team or that co-ed team which is sports
uh so by co-curricular we open it up to
include anything usually usually from
grades what middle middle Elementary
grades intermediate levels 34 right up
to grades 12 uh I'd rather not put down
a three through 12 I just like to
basically say in the next part the local
Board of educa of board of each School
District or the governing body of each
non-public school shall establish an
emergency action plan for responding uh
to co-curricular related injuries and
emergencies
so it's up to the local Board of each
School District to develop a plan and
wherever any of these things that are
defined the SP curricular would
occur I I put together my remarks here
you know and uh I'd like to just get
this all emailed out to you so you can
have a copy of it
um uh so
um I've made changes all the way through
this saying um it'd be a lot easier if I
could just email this to you in fact do
you have it right
now we could email you a copy of this
and you'd have it within two
seconds I'm a little hesitant in
referencing a lot of organ organizations
and associations and saying we will
follow their you know
procedures um which those procedures can
change um then statute has to change or
we it's just like uh we oftentimes do
with fire codes we identify a specific
fire code so we don't have to and
that's we don't always we don't take
necessarily the most recent or updated
fire code
um Rick yeah
um in that section where you were
talking about including all
co-curricular before you had said
something about all co-curricular and
and intermural activities is that what
you were planning on putting in there in
my copy I just added inter murals in
that list right after where it says
Athletics inter murals performing
groups they they travel just as much as
well too and uh I think that there's got
to be an emergency plan for all these
types of activities right I was just
making sure they were actually all going
to be covered because yeah everybody
should have an emergency action plan
yeah we have an attendee with this
[Music]
Tom no but let's let's uh try and get
this out everybody
[Music]
first
gun's trying to get this to
you chairman lad that's coming through I
thought in the testimony the person who
was presenting was talking about that
this is primarily for grades four to
eight as the high schools already have
these
documentations um particular for the
sport piece and as I'm looking at part
three it's the whole part three is is
Rel it's a sport I mean it's it's like
seem going way off the and I'm not
suggesting that the school building
doesn't have emergency plans it
shouldn't not have emergency plan unless
you're Jing that at all I'm just say I'm
reading this that whole P three was
specifically for school Sport and they
were focusing on middle school because
the high schools already have the train
all those pieces applicable I just
wonder if we're not really going Way
Beyond I'm not suggesting you shouldn't
modify it just seems like we're going
Way Beyond the intent of of what part
three was supposed to be and why it was
there because the middle schools weren't
doing it and they had the sports
programs yeah middle schools usually
have a combination of sportsin murals
and it's inter mural usually at the
elementary in high school it's usually
Sports and some inter mural
um the you have you have elementary
schools that are competing against other
elementary schools sometimes with
interal programs um they're traveling
they those kids are just as susceptible
to injury
or even if they're not traveling
um so I don't know why we wouldn't have
an emergency
plan established to address all our
students that are in co-curricular
activity well I I was if I may Rick I I
must suggesting you shouldn't all I'm
saying is will you open it up to all
kinds of co-curricular activities in the
school and every organization is
considered
co-curricular um you know and and as is
inter murals um the science club is
curric
the uh auto shop Club is C anything they
do that has in the school that's during
our after is co-curricular it's not
curricular so all I'm saying is I think
we've gone way as off off course here as
the the intent of part
three but I'm not suggesting there
shouldn't be emergency plans in all
schools I'm just saying you it just
seems to we've gone way way off course
when we when if that's our
thinking that's all
by part part three it's basically just
requiring action plans and I don't
understand why it's going away from the
intent of of of
part I say because in the The Art Club
doesn't have coaches it doesn't have
licensed athletic training it doesn't so
all those types of things things are
identified in part three uh were
identified uh for sport or interm
related athletic activities so once
again the the intent I think of this of
this change or addition to the the
regulation was not not to for all
co-curricula I understand your concerned
for everyone having safety protocols
it's sort of like that bus with no back
rear exit I I understand that all I'm
just saying is it seems like we're going
way off on this one and maybe maybe a
better way maybe a better way to address
it than try to re rewrite the entire you
know take out coaches licensed out
training is niia just that's all just
seems to we're wrong right right cherish
wrong
Q I hear you uh represent Mullen thank
you Mr chair um representative Woodcock
would it not be as simple if
representative lad put co-curricular in
as opposed uh co-curricular in inter
murals as opposed to using the word
Sports because Sports is part of
curricular and intermural activities
wouldn't it be just as simple as putting
employees coaches athletic trainers and
advisors because all of those
co-curriculars and intermurals have to
have advisors so if you just added the
word advisors I think it would globally
cover everybody may very may very well
uh M Mrs pom I mean
M's a fresh he's a fresh one
representative lad I hear that I hear
that feel free you feel free to
discipline him at any point in time well
you know I couldn't do it with some of
my cousins who grew up in Conway it's
it's just a strange atmosphere out
there um so the B had the shop in the
woods up there the north side of North
Conway so I guess what I'm I guess what
I'm saying here representative uh is
that I um agree with representative lad
that this would be a good opportunity to
get emergency plans in for all Student
Activities not just
Athletics my my concern is that you you
have various clubs and theater groups
working after school
hours um from you know getting ready for
plays or theater or there can be injury
occur and there's nobody else in the
building the school nurse has gone uh so
that's where I see that need um we don't
identify anywhere in our statute if you
look at the military compacts or you
work look elsewhere in terms of
homeschoolers coming and participating
in athletics we don't call it Athletics
or Sports we call it co-curricular
program and basically our co-curricular
definition includes everything that I
read with the exception of inner murals
and um that's due to the fact we mostly
referen to high school and upper levels
of middle school but now we're looking
at everything going up that has this
type of a program most likely you know I
I had an intermediate school at one time
and the grades four through six very
very active intermural
program uh so
um I I I think we miss something if we
don't have some kind of you might say
for um uh co-curricular shall include
those activities which are designed to
supplement enrich regular curriculum
programs of study provide opportunities
for Social Development and then and
encourage participating in clubs
Athletics and Inter murals stop right
there but you wouldn't have your
performing
groups uh which there could be issues
Dave you have your hand up yeah yeah
Rick um thanks thanks for this and and
um you know I think these are all really
good points and important points I guess
you know I don't want to lose the baby
on on on this one and if starting with
sports um you know gets it gets it in
and we certainly didn't have a hearing
on you know other co-curricular
activities um and what the what the
impact um would be on school districts
but uh but if if we're in agreement on
on Sports then then then I think we've
got something in place with the with the
Senate on on that part and if we do
Amendment if we do amend it there's a
risk we lose the whole thing so um and
clearly there's been a lot more I think
incidences I mean I I bet a lot of us
have have
coached um I you know I coached Alpine
assistant coached Alpine you know here
in hopkington for a bunch of years and
yep I escorted kids with broken legs and
and um and stuff off um in fact we're
skiing at Blackwater over at Proctor
Academy and um and you know driving kids
to conquered hospital so um yeah I mean
and and and clearly the stuff that makes
news aren't the ski injuries they're the
football injuries you know the heat
stroke and some of the other things that
are referenced in in the in the prop in
the language here so I I'm I mean I'm
good I'm good either way but I just
don't want to lose it well we we also
have in the legislation that was given
to us by the Senate it speaks to grades
4 through
12 so we're talking about elementary
school as well it also goes down and
addresses um document the proper
procedures to be followed when a student
sustains a serious injury or illness
while participating in school sponsor
sports or other athletic activity are we
talking in rural um you you better start
defining athletic other athletic
activity um the the bill as it's written
Now Sports is governed by nhiaa that's
high school sports uh represent Woodcock
understands and knows that it does not
govern Middle School uh seventh grade or
sixth grade or fourth grade or fifth
great um it it so there but this bill
does address 4th through
12th so what's being done at grades 4
and 12 I as an elementary principal for
years can tell you that we've had you
know when I was a principal over Rumford
main we took our kids on competition all
the way up to rangley main um that's a
hell of a ride um over the height of
land and back down up the Rangely so um
we we called them in
murals so yeah
um so another another question on on
this Rick um um is this language that's
being adopted in other states and and is
it really providing a blueprint um that
that the state and school districts can
follow for um um for sports 4 through 12
um and by if we do expand it right now
are we are we having to reinvent
something I mean I'm just I'm I'm just
you
know again don't want to lose the
ability to move quickly
um well I think
I has her hand up I didn't know okay I
think the answer your questions perhaps
what you ought to do is that I don't
know if Glenn's got that out to you
right now y um everybody should have it
you should look it over and and see
where you are in that
uh okay you've got all of 148 so you'll
have the next part as well um there
there was when we're looking at parts of
this bill right here the way it's
written I do have some real significant
questions when you're sh sharing medical
information with a coach um how are you
doing it where are you storing it
where's the coach keeping it how
confidential is it uh are we following
Hippa are we following furpa um that's
all important and um how much does a
coach have to know every you know all
the medical history of a student where's
it start and stop um
so um uh that's in the amendment that
you that you were sent by myself I've
tried to identify that um
so I think the best way to because we
could spend a lot of time here
discussing this right now I'd hope that
you would have had had this this uh
material earlier so you could look it
over so represent likeus yeah I I you
know I did print it off now and look at
it um I don't see that the changes are
drastic compared to what the Senate did
and I can't see why the Senate would
object to expanding from Sports to
co-curricular and I will say there are
plenty of other things you don't think
about like math club doesn't seem like
it would be very difficult math club
does travel for competitions and I did
have a case where a student ran into a
door and split his head open so I mean
it's a stupid thing but those things
happen so I'm just saying you know
having a plan in place for whatever just
make
sense so I like the co-curricular I
think we should go with
it well okay just look look this over I
don't think we're going to resolve
anything today it's a work session to
try to try to provide folks
uh areas which may be of concern areas
that are strength of strength um I think
the whole concept is a good one uh I
think we need to tailor it though to
um what we what we need here in New
Hampshire I don't know how many athletic
trainers there are in all the high
schools 43% of the schools don't have
them I I would say that's that's right
yeah it's probably about
half I know we don't have one up in
Woodsville and Woodsville has a pretty
strong division for baseball team and
athletic
program so um I think it's important
that coaches and the employees that are
associated with it um have this
training want to go on to the next part
y
yeah uh repesent Porter you have your
hand up yes Mr chair I just wanted to
apologize I I'm going to need to leave
the meeting and I didn't want to just go
blank on
you thank you for letting me be part of
your committee today and I hope you to
see you again soon thanks for joining us
margorie part five uh relative to
environmental science and outdoor or
four part
four oh a definition of a private uh
postsecondary Career School we're
talking
yoga remember that yep
um I personally don't see a need for a
part n on
it so um so Rick yeah yeah I I think
part n is the part that
actually uh
excludes the um
uh Fitness training and recreational
Wellness facilities and
so if if you take away n
then only such facilities that have an
annual growth tuition of 100,000 or less
are
excluded
yeah I I don't I don't have any
ownership in any part of this bill
um yeah so so I you know I did get I did
get get some correspondence from um from
um uh the folks who are representing the
uh the the industry um on this
particularly the well not only um you
know personal uh recreational Wellness
you know fitness clubs but also the um
the uh industry that trains the
instructors for these um for these clubs
and um they actually suggest just a a
minor um change in and to I think
address uh uh some concerns that um that
Steve Appleby had um expressed during
the hearing and and that's basically
replaced the word instructional program
the term instructional programs in um
paragraph n with vocational
instruction and um so um so it would it
would exclude the um Fitness and and
wellness um uh
you know folks because you know that's
really not uh I mean most people don't
go to Planet Fitness for vocational
training purposes it's you know to you
know work off whatever and um um uh and
so it would exclude them and then for
the for the um for the facilities that
do provide vocational training it would
um require them to have assurity bond if
they have the if they meet the tuition
thres
threshold
okay so you just basically scratch
instructional programs and replace a
locational instruction yep that's right
okay two hands
uh represent yeah the
light yeah um since this is about
providing aity Bond aren't the only
people we really care about providing a
shity bond is those who take um pay
payment upfront as opposed to those who
do it like on a weekly or monthly or
whatever basis and shouldn't we just be
saying that those are the ones that need
to put up a security Bond those who
collect you know the fees up front
because isn't that what we're worried
about if they go bankrupt or or whatever
people should be able to get their money
back but if they haven't already paid
the money in then there's no money to be
given
back so so that's in a diff so so um
yeah if I can address that real quick
Rick that's in that's in a different
part of the law that's 188 gon 3 and so
if you wanted to put some some you know
change how that shity Bond practice is
done for all um Industries then then
that's the that's the place there but
for this it's really just it's really
just saying as it pertains to Fitness
instruction if it's vocational training
Fitness instruction ction um then in
tuition's above
$100,000 then you you you follow the
shity bond um
procedure represent Celli thank you but
also if you uh do not strike in um you
are basically carving out a um benefit
for just uh Fitness and Wellness uh
programs rather than um any um career
school with a tuition of under
$100,000 um you're excluding those um
from uh this legislation and requiring
them to have a shy Bond would we want to
make it um a little bit uh broader
rather than a carve out for just these
businesses because I didn't think we
were allowed to do carve outs for
specific
businesses well I I think I think this
one here is to eliminate the confusion
that uh that that that Stephen appelbe
laid out which is all right so um
instruction is instruction is the local
Planet Planet Fitness is that considered
a um you know something that should be
regulated under the Department of
Education um because they provide
Fitness instruction and and I I think
clearly that's not what the what this
level of vocation what this vocational
training um uh chapter is designed to do
so so what this specifically does is
clear up any any um misunderstanding as
it applies to uh Fitness
instruction um and uh makes it specific
to vocational training uh for for you
know for Training Fitness instructors
and and then sets the um set and and
sets the um the charity
Bond hey Dave um this is uh Senator
Ward's Bill I'm sure she got it from
doe and from uh is Steve applebe still
around oh he's got his hand raised y
let's let's bring him in okay well he
justed it
welcome again Mr
applebe good afternoon everyone good
afternoon Steve are you listening to our
conversation here
yes yes question can I answer I I
thought it was a carb out too so that's
why I was saying it Nix it but you know
if there's more to this I'd like to know
so um uh just if I could answer that in
one moment I want to go back it was
mentioned before about schools that
don't take tuition up front that collect
potentially day of class they're already
Exempted so elsewhere in statute or in
rule um we've already Exempted schools
that don't collect tuition up front so
they're covered the addition of line n
that we talked about during the
hearing if you were to strike that
entirely then um there would be no issue
from the standpoint my understanding the
Y schools who prompted this bill
um that line n doesn't exempt them if
they're over 100,000 in tuition but
because of its reference to Fitness
instruction there is some question here
at the doe if that that this almost
expands our scope of lure which we're
not in support of obviously um so
eliminating line n should still achieve
what the
yoga um uh Community was was was asking
which is that their smallest schools be
Exempted um and it exempts by the way 14
other small schools around the state who
are in a variety of
vocations so that the the the line of
100,000 or less intuition being exempt
that's fine but that line n does does
make things a little wider and is a
little bit
concerning so you would not have a
problem if we struck in no not at all
are we talking schools or
vocational programs or
vocational are these schools so we call
them you know air quotes schools um it's
it's postsecondary
education and um what we license are
schools that are you know that teach
people a profession something they can
go out and learn earn a living with now
of course that's a slippery slope right
but the the folks that we license are um
are bartending schools uh computer
schools dog groming schools where they
actually teach a
vocation to a student who can then go
out and get a job with that vocation um
we we do have several um uh hair you
know uh cosmetology type massage type
schools as well um that are licensed but
in all of these cases these are these
are uh vocations that they're leading to
so if a school advertises that it
teaches people how to um an occupational
skill then they fall under this this
statue and that's where the yoga folks
initially ran into trouble was they
advertise that they teach people how to
become yoga
teachers that's a profession that's no
different than any other school that
that teaches someone how to be a
professional dog groomer a professional
bartender so hence you know that's why
we're this is
here is they they had some heartburn
over this this
issue thanks Steve do do are there any
other questions for Steve from the
committee Mullen represent Mullen thank
you Mr chair and thank you Steve for
taking the question so with regards to
entities that do make over $100,000 a
year
um obviously the reason to have them
take out aity bond is so that there's
protection for people that have paid
tuition or whatever uh into the program
if we were to strike
n is that protection offered somewhere
else in
statute well n is actually
new okay so that's now so it didn't
exist prior to this bill all right okay
fair enough thank you that's all I need
to
know right and Rick the and Steve can
confirm me these are exemptions right
yes these are exemptions from from the
um the the U lure requirement lure
requirements for for postsecondary
career schools and and you know in the
case of what's being um uh discussed
here um
then are you know programs that don't
have curriculum and and and things like
that so my understanding is that is that
these these uh Fitness and recreational
Wellness um uh programs do want to be uh
Exempted because they don't they don't
really feel like they they fall under um
what's the private post-secondary career
schools and
um
uh and let's see I'm also just sort of
looking I think there may be somebody
from um that
represents these folks that that can
certainly talk to it um with greater
familiarity I think they might have
their hand up a couple of hands
raised I don't know if it's Amy or Tom I
I mean it could be Tom could be Amy okay
does anybody have any further from Steve
here
so Steve I want to make sure I
understand if we take out n m will still
take care of the concerns of the people
the wellness and yoga instructors and
whatever all of them fall under M and so
we don't need n because M takes care of
them is that correct that's exactly
correct and in fact um as I've said n
widens the scope m is very succinct
any school with $100,000 a year or less
of gross tuition is Exempted from
lure um and because in N you'll notice
the 100,000 is there again so in fact n
is almost redundant m is any school of
any kind and is a specific category you
know specific uh types of schools but
they still the 100,000 so it n also does
seem redundant because M takes care of
the issue thank
you
okay um my constituent um feels that any
income any
uh regardless of income this is going to
be a problem for them so are you talking
about taking out M as a
mar so Emma would still put a
restriction in there yeah it's very
would be 100 or thousand or less it's
it's a that's a real clear L Line in the
Sand whereas the other sort of goes the
other way with with a
car hey hey Rick yeah yeah I don't see
how it can how how M can or sorry how
how n Nancy can can broaden it given the
fact you've already got M
that is one restriction n can only be
further
limiting it can only be further limiting
it might be redundant but I don't see
how it can be read any other
way let me read it again to myself go
ahead Glen yeah um and is talking about
these
specific types of businesses but with a
gross income of over
$100,000 well will require insurity Bond
but that that provision that necessity
is already covered as stated at the end
of the sentence uh in 188g Colon
3 which requires the sh of bond so any
entity per M as in Mary um any entity
with a tuition of under under
$100,000 is exempt including these uh
Fitness uh
programs so so let so Le let's say
you've got a a local gym that that where
where where there's um uh somebody that
leads a cycling class and that local gym
has 300 members uh and the membership is
$100 a month so they have gross receipts
of$ 400,00 th000 a year um I I don't
think that would be uncommon for for a
local gym um they wouldn't qual they
they wouldn't be exempt under M but they
would be exempt under n as in
Nancy Yes actually they would be exempt
representative luno already with the
existing statute if the training they're
the classes they're conducting are
avocational in nature so if they're
conducting spin classes unless they're
teaching people how to conduct a spin
class as a profession right it's an
avocational spin class they're exempt
already under existing
law so again my the point that I've been
making with this part and is in Nancy is
by specifically naming teaching Fitness
and recreational wellness and not
delineating the vocational piece which
you mentioned earlier we've widened the
net not restricted it and um whereas
eliminating all ofen as in Nancy um
would then revert to the current statute
which states that the education must be
vocational in nature in order for
someone to to fall under that statute so
the spin class at the local gym the
fitness class in the
park yoga class those are already
Exempted
so where where's the disconnect here
with the with the industry I I think the
industry has I I think
um they are hung up on the fact that
although they advertise classes for
people to become yoga
teachers they have been hung up on the
fact that 90 plus% of their students
never go on to do that and those that do
it's a side job they do it part-time or
as a hobby job where they make a little
bit of money and many of the yoga studio
owners they have told us um even that is
a side job that's not their main source
of income well our statutes don't
delineate primary sources of income and
secondary if you earn income from it
that's a profession that's a
vocation therefore um you fall under
under the current statute so I think the
disconnect
is that although most of their students
never pursue it as a profession we don't
have the ability at the department to to
to distinguish or or parse that um it is
they advertise it as vocational training
therefore they fall under the current
statute so so so a yoga studio that
trains yoga
instructors that has less than I'm sorry
um uh more than $100,000 a year in uh um
in in Gross
receips would fall under this um this
doe
regulation yes provided two other two
other three other pieces one they have a
physical presence in New
Hampshire which makes sense right um two
that they charge they collect tuition up
front as opposed to day of class and
three that that tuition exceeds
$800
so if they don't if they don't meet any
any one of those they're also
Exempted and by way of student
protection I would just I think I
mentioned this in my testimony but we
did have a precipitous closure in
December of this past year that um we
had approximately 71 students at a u
nursing school that closed and because
of the bond those students are now
collecting refunds on their tuition
right right
so here we are guys
gals
um n in or
out re can can we can we just hear from
I I think it might be Amy or
Tom let me see who's who we got they
both have their hand raised Tom has had
his hand raised for a significant
portion of this
okay you want me to bring them forward
try go over the top and work down
okay what are you doing watching the Red
Sox play no he's watching up this this
quality control quality
control Mr Cal you've been uh promoted
welcome to education
thank you chairman lad members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Tom prol from demur and prol I actually
had my hand raised in regards to part
three of the bill as I represent the New
Hampshire athletic trainers Association
uh we had worked with Senator Ganon on
that on that piece of this Omnibus Bill
and I know the committee probably
doesn't want to go backwards uh however
you know we I did want to say that we
don't have a problem with expanding it
to co-curricular activities however
there's a specific representative you'd
like me to work with on the proposed
amended language I'm happy to do
so thanks Tom thank you for being
patient is there someone you'd like me
to reach out to to get a copy and work
with look I I'll send you the copy that
I have as a draft how about that Tom
that's a great starting point Thank you
very much and I believe Amy is with the
uh yoga line so she would be a good
person to speak with on that portion of
the
bill all right thank you
thanks do you do you have Tom's
email I do not but I will get it Amy
keep your hand
up
okay welcome to education go ahead
please hi everyone can you hear me yes
yes great thank you so much for having
me on my name is Amy go uh I'm an
attorney for yoga Alliance I'm with the
firm Pillsbury winr just like to add
some clarity uh there was a question
earlier about what's the disconnect with
the industry so let me walk through this
a little bit um there's two Provisions
that are that are in consideration we
have M for Mary which exempts you know
institutions that make under
$100,000 and we agree that's great for
small businesses in any industry but the
reason why n is needed and is a Nancy
from our perspective is because we've
experienced in recent months for the
first time um certain types of advanced
yoga classes being uh reached out to and
asked to be licensed as career schools
and this turns on the type of yoga class
that we're talking about within the yoga
industry and this is are the community I
should say and this is global worldwide
and across the United States highlevel
yoga classes are called yoga teacher
trading that's a term of Art in the
community right it it it signifies a
highlevel class where you learn very
high level skills but as Mr applebe
mentioned the majority of people are not
taking these classes to make yoga their
profession and if they do go on to teach
yoga it's because they have a day job
and they're teaching maybe a Class A
week right as something that is for them
it's a personal interest it's wellness
and for this reason these classes have
been mischaracterized as career schools
it's not just the Sher bond issue
there's also a host of other lure
requirements that are simply
inapplicable to a school like this they
don't have grades for example right it's
not a Traditional School environment
with transcripts Etc that would match up
with what we think of as a career School
now as Mr applebe very eloquently put
the issue has been is the department
doesn't feel like they can make a
distinction based on the way the
statute's currently written they're
saying we we there's our hands are tied
the way that statute is written because
you have the word teacher in your
program you're vocational so the reason
n is needed is to give an exemption to
these programs which really shouldn't be
regulated as vocational schools frankly
are not regulated in the majority of
other states as vocational schools and
also aligned with New Hampshire law the
reason the second Clause of n the one
that you know adds a shity bond for
those schools that have more than
$100,000 in revenue is to align with
other parts of the statute we understand
there are consumer protection concerns
and so we said okay maybe it's fair that
those large schools provide a shity bond
but if they provide a shy Bond under n
they wouldn't be subject to all the
other lure requirements that are a bad
fit for a yoga program so that's why n
is needed as an individual standal and
exemption and I hope that brings Clarity
and I'm happy to answer any questions
you
have repres
leas M Alicia I can't hear you
sorry I thought I'd already unmuted me
thank you Amy for coming on and
explaining that to us I do have a
question for you um if
we just leave M Mary in and take out
Nancy are there any yoga schools or
instruction centers that would be caught
up in that or would Mary take care of
all of the um schools that are concerned
about this so that you wouldn't have to
do so that no yoga instruction schools
would have to to do any of this stuff
thank you that's a that's a really
important question so the answer is I
don't know because I don't have an
accounting of every yoga program or
quite frankly you know programs that are
aligned with yoga or similar to yoga in
the state but I think that if we if to
operate and just say well M solves the
problem right we're actually missing a
separate issue which is that these
advanced yoga classes have been
mischaracterized so it means that we
open the door in the future if there is
a larger program for them to also be
mischaracterized so it would seem to be
better to create Clarity within the law
about what the concept is of the
vocational program so that we don't have
this issue outstanding going forward
into the future
thank
you further
questions thank you very
much so any further discussion on
this anybody have it resolved in their
mind everybody
confused
[Music]
yeah okay ready to move on to part five
so where where do you want to go on this
on that one
Rick how do you how do you
determine an instructional program who
decides whether 80% of what we do here
is for teaching teachers how to instruct
the other 20% is for you know somebody
to come have a an experience to for
wellness or to
recreate well the other part of that is
she's talking about yoga but it doesn't
say that in here it says Fitness and
recreational Wellness which is really a
much bigger category and I mean that
could even include gym teachers which
should be which should fit under this
so so I don't see that n fits what we're
actually trying to
fix
[Music]
you think rson hops yeah um chairman lad
um Mr applebe gave um a list of three
criteria I can't remember the third one
but one was 800 plus for a class yeah um
being in new hire and then there was the
third one so um you all will remember
that um yoga person that I had attended
a retreat it was a one-time thing $1,000
for the weekend but it was a whole
weekend which included everything she
would she would fall under this am I not
correct she would be taxed or
uh needed to to get a license pay the
fees um so it's it's not necessarily a
source of income for her it's so one and
done maybe she does it twice a year I
really don't know particularly but I'm
thinking about her as this is
going would
she would she have had over aund th
$1,000 from that in the course of a
year oh no I think no I think there were
probably M would have t m would take
care of
her
right Mr chair $1,000 you could go to
Atlanta go there okay I
know yes re Leon uh thank you Mr chair
it seems like we have two issues here in
N we're casting a very wide net on the
off on the chance that any of these
these uh programs are large enough that
the name teacher in the training program
is going to cause a problem now right
now this is a self-identified teacher
training tring and we're trying to
change the statutes for more than just
this yoga instruction because of a term
of art if this isn't currently a problem
then perhaps we should get rid of N and
address this look at it maybe for next
session to figure out if there's a
better way to make these things that are
teacher style training maybe there needs
to be some modification in how it's how
it's addressed in the term of Art and
that's not really something to change
the statutes for everybody else
um for this one chance to catch somebody
in this
problem yeah I I you know trying to
distinguish between you know what you
get going to that for a recreational
purpose or you going to become an
instructor a teacher who discerns that
does the Department of Education well we
have a doe of one person that's not
going to do
that and and so then it's up to the
individual entity to do that and how are
you which way you going to go are you
going to go well maybe 60 here 40 there
no maybe 20 then 80 you know depending
upon where I filter out in terms of what
kind of benefits I'm G to get out of
It's seems very subjective to me and
it's it seems to be a bit of a consumer
protection issue too perhaps people
understand that teacher training isn't
really teacher training but this whole
point is to protect people um about
their what they may consider an
investment in a career so having that
name in it could bring bigger questions
so I think that it doesn't seem like
it's a current pressing problem right
now getting R of in and looking at this
more comprehensively when we can
actually meet in person and do this
might make sense represent cordelli yes
and uh am might solve the problem for
all these um uh yoga
instructional um programs that we
discussed and that we not testimony of
um schools that have the to gross
tuition of over
$100,000 further discussion from anybody
out there so Dave how you feel about
this right now yeah I mean I I I think
it's pretty clear that uh and is and
Nancy is not talking about um you know
keing State un you know uh that's
educating uh PE
instructors in fact um those schools
that confer degrees are already carved
out of of this statute so when you look
at um at
188g I don't know one something like
that um uh it already it already talks
about that I think I think you know and
is and Nancy's pretty specific here when
it's when it's talking about nope
this this is no not talking about um um
your local um um you know gym or Fitness
club and it's not talking about
organizations that uh that teach um uh
yoga instructors to be yoga instructors
and uh unless and and if you're if
you're a big you know Fitness Company
like there are some like less Mills and
stuff like that I don't know if they do
any instruction in New Hampshire that
that take in more than
$100,000 then um then you know you'd pay
you you'd have to put up the shity bond
um uh but otherwise you wouldn't be
subject to the other licensing
regulations uh uh you know I you know I
I don't see the harm in leaving leaving
it in I mean uh you know otherwise it's
just it it um and is and Nancy I don't
think makes it subjective I think it
makes it very specific uh otherwise uh
you're you're gonna have to dance around
the other ones and you know try to
figure out you know noncredit non-degree
granting Authority you know and get into
um you know um a fight over those things
so I I think it clear I think n clears
it
up any other
thoughts everybody here is
sleeping I kind of go the other way in
that N I think makes it more confusing
and i' just ass soon just see just m in
um which yes would would
um help other businesses other than just
yoga instructors that may have nothing
to do with Fitness but if they're making
if they're not making that much I don't
see a problem anyways but
um a r to me teaching Fitness and
recreational Wellness is just just a big
category
and
[Music]
next well we'll we'll see next Thursday
when everybody brings forth their
amendments yeah so Rick what why don't
we what why don't we bring bring them
forward both ways um you know if there's
if there's people that want N Out we can
I mean I'm I think everybody's saying
leave Mary em Mary em is and Mary in
leave that one in and have one without n
and have one with n with instructional
programs um changed to vocational
instruction and then we can we can hack
through it during the
exac probably will be the only way of
resolving so we'll leave Mike and
November
we yeah we can leave it in and and then
take one November out yeah
yeah
so let's move
on yeah I need some coffee here yeah
have some coffee out
there I'll take four milks in
it okay next part five relative to
environmental and outdoor
education um if you've received anything
from myself you know that I'm looking uh
to uh this this build really has two
parts the first part is finding
basically session law which goes away in
a while anyways a lot of why we do this
why it's more of a a background um the
big the teeth in this thing is really
when you get down to the criteria for an
adequate
education and that's where the the teeth
of this bill is
there um and it's it's there as a result
of some of the things we're trying some
we're trying to do in Career Technical
Education Without thr recreation in our
state as an as an industry and they're
teaching more outdoor recreation courses
at the CTE centers now than they have in
in a
while so look uh I've changed the part
five title to read relative to
environmental science and outdoor
recreation one because I think that the
environmental science is something we're
speaking to in the criteria for an
adequate
education and outdoor recreation I've
already talked
about I took all the findings and
stripped them all out um there's a lot
of stuff there which is nice know it
leads up to the therefore we shall um
it's all session law it all
disappears so then what I'd like to just
talk quickly about where I should go of
course it's just Rick lad
um under the criteria for an adequate
education and I've communicated this
with the maker of this bill too with the
senator and I have agreement on this
part the knowledge of biological
physical and Earth Sciences including
Crossing out
climate and put earth
scientists including environmental
science that investigates the complex
complex interaction of physical chemical
and biological processes that take place
on the earth to enable them to
understand and appreciate the world and
the engineering socioeconomic and
geopolitical challenges around them what
I've done here and working with um Dave
is try to blend in language we have in
HB 242 dealing with the the latter part
there and dealing with the biological
physical and Earth sciences and how that
impacts the engineering soci economic
and geopolitical challenges we're facing
in this world and we're facing some very
serious issues climate is going to
generate a lot of controversy there's a
lot of issues on climate and even though
it's a part of science it's also an
issue which is uh debatable amongst
people as how it's being used and how
it's being
interpreted the second part which I I
may
modified
deals with uh another uh uh area that
would be modified within our uh criteria
for an adequate education we already
have sound sound wellness envir and
environmental
practices and I and then of course the
bill had including Recreation to enable
them that's that's uh the way the bill
was and the next uh uh criteria
are
are for an adequate education and skills
for lifelong learning including
interpersonal and technical skills I
took out Environmental Education skills
to enable them to learn work and
communicate and participate effectively
in a changing society and
environment and so that those are the
changes I I'd like to you know that I'd
like to propose uh it's now open to that
the whole bill is open or part five is
open for
discussion by the way I emailed that's
been all emailed to
you
discussion chairman lad are these
changes you discussed with Senator
Waters the I I am not discussed with him
the part the findings all those findings
I I just I took them out by
myself um after the advisory council
meeting he said he had been trying to
get in touch with you to talk over some
of these I I talked with him regarding
the latter part the criteria for
inadequate
education must be two days ago
okay thank you not the finings I like
I've said before there's a lot of
information there
yes but it's nothing that's going to
remain in stat
law it's all session law it's all going
to be
gone it doesn't doesn't put anything in
the
statute it's just
[Music]
information
Rick oh represent leus I didn't see up
in the corner here yeah I just had a
question uh in part seven you took out
Environmental Education
skills um I'm
wondering I guess I would have put en
invironmental
skills just because it is important for
lifelong learning Etc um I'm just
wondering why you took it out that's
all
well we have to have those interpersonal
skills and technical skills which are
associated with working communicating
participating effectively in our
changing society and
environment
uh I I I'm looking at the skills that
contribute to how we change and and work
within our environment so
um environmental skills alici I'd ask
you Define them
please environmental skills are going to
be basically using many of the the
subjects which we teach could be in
geology it could be in geography it
could be in uh all the different types
of biological sciences and physical
sciences and chemical
Sciences so you think the technological
skills would be sufficient to cover all
of the environmental skills
well
interpersonal working with each
other pardon me and technical skills yes
uh to enable them to learn work
communicate and participate effectively
in our changing environment I'm not
talking about environmental skills um
the environmental
skills I I just I'm having a hard time
finding that in isolation you go look up
environment and you're going to find
find all these subjects that we teach
and we
do so I guess I'm Clarity too I guess I
was just looking because you put it up
above including environmental science
and so to me the things the skills that
you learn from environmental science
would be environmental skills so I'm
wondering why you took it back out when
you put it in up above it just seemed
environmental science is the science of
environment and it it
incorporates many many subjects uh it's
not a science unto itself it's almost a
sub topic Within These larger
categories it could be underneath
geography could be underneath uh biology
chemistry
physics yes repr cardelli no thank you
uh I think in one place you're talking
about knowledge and the other place
you're talking about skills yeah um I
don't know what environmental
skills um I I don't know what that would
be I would think gardening and uh tree
trimming and all those kinds of things
would come under environmental skills is
Eric croi still here because we
discussed this at the advisory council
is Eric
still from the Department can ask no
no when I talk with uh Senator Waters he
said the most important part is that we
make sure we got outdoor recre including
outdoor recreation that is a program
which gives then direction to the for
technical education to get into the the
industry or the business of outdoor
recreation which is a key industry to
our
state uh profession and with that as a
part of the criteria for an adequate
education it gives them the open door
the green light to pursue uh that type
of programming in the in the Career
Centers if we have three hands represent
um and did
you we've sort of touched around it in
the last minute we live in an
environment it's a
noun what skills are associated with the
word environment I I can't make
them L one to the
other
you have your hand
up off I think
m not not an MD you're still muted there
you go thanks
thank you thank you Mr chairman as a
former student of
geology perhaps some terminology might
get us through this current bind I'm
suggesting I'm thinking for instance
that titrating would be a skill in
biology Reading Core ice samples would
be a skill but when you start talking
about environmental skills you're really
talk talking about environmental
activities or something like that when
you say gardening and things of that
sort and so you're displaying a a
conclusion that certain activities are
better for the environment they may or
they may not be in some cases there are
agricultural examples that aren't
particularly good for the environment in
some people's opinion so I think we're
kind of hung up here on what categories
the these activities fall into rather
than whether or not there's such a thing
as an environmental
skill that's my my twoo sense
worth thank
you furthera you have your hand up
then Corell I don't know she's your hand
up no
okay we have three hands up no wait
minute yeah
yeah just following on what rep Ford was
saying in that there are ways of doing
things which I mean there are skills
that you learn for ways of doing things
to not harm the environment to that well
that you learn how the things that you
do affect your
environment how you handle the even home
pesticide you and whatever how do you
handle it those are skills how do you do
things to keep it from running off into
the water those are all skills that we
would hope people would learn so that
they don't do things like kill off the
bees and all that kind of stuff and so I
see these skills as still being
important lifelong things because what
we do as we go on as we interact with
our environment does have an effect on
it and I think we need to know how to do
it in a sound and and responsible manner
okay I if I can interrupt Eric is back
on the attendee list if we could get him
to come into the meeting to explain like
the definitions that were being used for
outdoor recreation and
environment and what they were looking
at the CTE level for that sure we can
ask you in
thanks
welcome back Mr
[Music]
Crower are you there Eric yes he is good
afternoon again
afternoon okay we're we're uh going over
the last part of uh s sp4
48 it's a part of the bill which deals
with the uh relative to environmental
and outdoor
education okay and uh what I've done is
I've modified it in a in a possibility
here rela to to
environmental science and outdoor
recreation and jumping down through all
the findings getting into the criteria
for inadequate education I think that's
the most important part of this
bill um I've written that uh knowledge
of biological physical and Earth
Sciences including environmental science
that investigates the complex
interaction of physical chemical and
biological processes that take place on
the earth to enable them to understand
this is the kids and appreciate the
world and the engineering and
socioeconomic and geopolitical
challenges around them then um the
there's a a criteria for an adequate
adequate education which is number six
soundness sound wellness and
environmental practices so we have
environmental practices already in law
uh and I put in it's in PR uh comma
including outdoor recreation to enable
them to enhance their own well-being as
well as that of others uh that's already
in law with the exception of in
including outdoor Recreation which was
put in the original Bill to assist to
give um the
centers uh the green light in terms of
here is a criteria for an adequate
education dealing with the outdoor
recreation industry and moving folks
forward with that those skills and that
knowledge this the seventh area that um
so that part remained the same uh part
seven says skills for lifelong Lear
learning including interpersonal now the
bill had Environmental Education skills
I scratched out Environmental Education
skills there and left it and technical
skills which is what we have to enable
them to learn work communicate and part
participate effectively in a changing
society and
environment so um those those are the
changes that you know I've offered um I
I I think one of the key components is
maintaining outdoor
recreation um and then speaking to
environmental science which is spoken to
in the Roman three and then uh having
skills to work and live within a
changing society and environment so uh
I'll let representative Cornell she
asked for you um to come in again on
this and represent Cornell you can ask
um um Eric uh well I think there were a
lot of questions about what
environmental skills were and what it
would be and I I think we had a lot of
discussion on that Monday in The
Advisory Council about the competencies
for outdoor use and um how things would
be different depending on which CTE
Center would be doing it and how it
could be embedded into different CTE
areas and um I I don't know about the
crossing out of the Environmental
Education skills I thought that was
something that we had talked about
Monday that sounded important I just
wanted to get your feedback on some of
this Eric sure thanks uh and and part
parts of this are definitely in my world
and and parts are I think belong to one
of the other divisions uh at the doe
that oversees the stem and I know when
Senator Waters drafts some of these
things that includes a number of us at
the doe uh but the outdoor recreation
definitely um is part of our world and
it was something that uh at the CTE
centers we had already started talking
about uh but uh I think representative
Cornelio hit it right on the head that
we just discussed the fact that outdoor
recreation and its impact on the
environment are very different depending
on where you are in the state and uh we
the examples we used were if a school
was in the North Country for them
outdoor recreation might have a lot more
to do with
um managing the forest areas and hiking
and fishing whereas outdoor recreation
in The Lakes Region might involve Power
Sports and the impact of those Power
Sports on the environment would be very
different than people hiking and fishing
up in the North Country uh and U but
making sure that all of them included
whatever these students the programs
were how they impacted the environment
so I think it is very important to make
sure that keeping the phrasing up of uh
impact on the environment or
Environmental Education uh is relevant
for all of the students across the
state thank you further further
questions of Eric represent Mullen you
have your hand up yeah I do uh it's more
of a comment than uh a question Mr chair
uh if you go back to the sections that
you crossed out I believe what Eric is
referencing uh Senator Waters started
with Roman numeral
5 therefore it is in the public interest
to provide environmental and outdoor
recreation education for New Hampshire
students where it starts there it goes
into the next statement which says
environmental lit literacy requires
having an understanding of the natural
world and the capacity to interpret
environmental systems which is what Eric
is talking about uh and then it goes on
to define environmental
literacy as uh achieved through
Environmental Education and outdoor
recreational education Environmental
Education integrates handson
project-based
classroom community
experiences uh I'm sure many of you are
reading it now outdoor recreation
education includes instruction in
outdoor recreational activities and
preparation for participation in the
outdoor recreation
industry um that language to me does not
look like feel-good language that
language to me sounds like essential
language because I think it puts the
importance of recreation and knowledge
of its impact on the
environment front and center so I would
suggest that we might want to think
about um reinstating perhaps some of
that language into whatever it is that
we move forward with because I think it
does put parameters around what those
definitions
are would you agree Eric there's my
question that was very loaded uh no I
um especially in New Hampshire I think
it is absolutely vital and important
that that
students uh are exposed to the
information around whatever how whatever
they're doing will be impacting the
environment as moving forward in their
careers and and making sure that
whatever language you put in as um as
required education for students includes
that in some way shape or
form repres Hopson yeah I think I think
I understand a little bit better um what
rep Mullen and and Mr prow worth were
talking about as far as um that being
the the core knowledge content and maybe
that does need to be in a separate place
but uh as far as under Roman numeral 7
the Environmental Education skills that
to me seems
misplaced what this paragraph is talking
about is lifelong skills in other words
how do you communicate your message it's
more of the
um uh be being able to communicate being
able to get your thought across it's
more of a of
a obviously I didn't pass that
class but
um the the fundamentals not necessarily
the core knowledge does does that make
sense technological
skills um to participate effectivly
effectively in changing
Society um those are all the day-to-day
skills whereas the core environment is
the core knowledge am I making
sense but the bill is titled relevant to
environmental and outdoor recreation so
those skills are relevant to what the
bill
is but in that particular paragraph you
would use you could take that paragraph
out and put it into any content
knowledge into any content
area do you know what I'm saying those
those particular skills so anyway that's
that was just my
thought further questions
discussion represent like
us can't hear
you can't hear you Alicia I I know I
couldn't get the little arrow ex kep
giving me a hand and not an arrow so I
couldn't
unmute there you go you got it so I just
my I like the environmental skills but
the Environmental Education skills I
don't know that that makes sense I would
take the education word out of that but
leave environmental skills in and I the
reason I okay so the reason I keep
pushing this is because I have seen too
many times when people don't have those
environmental skills they don't
understand how what they do affects the
world the environment and
everything and and that is a lifelong
learning thing is how to make sure you
don't
dump the you know oh I I have a garden
and I want to keep the bugs off so I'm
going to spray this stuff that's then
going to wash down into my water source
or it's or put too much on or not cover
myself and then I'm going to be exposed
to it myself and have problems I think
that there are skills that just normal
people as adults need to not only know
but know how to keep up with know how to
you know as as technology Etc changes I
think people need to
know and know how to learn those things
so I think environmental skills are
important for everybody who interacts
with the environment which is just about
everybody in One Way or Another so I
just see that as following into this
whole section I would take the education
word out but environmental skills as
something that it's a lifelong learning
kind of thing is how do these things
that I'm doing affect my
environment you know I think it's I
think it's important uh Alicia I got a
question for you what is the difference
between environmental skills and
environmental practices which is already
in
law because this section we're talking
about lifelong learning and so lifelong
learning would be continuing
environmental skills
as we go along as things change as
Technologies
change so I think it's
just you know we've put environmental
science in there that's when what we're
going to be
studying um environmental where was it
it shows up because it's in this whole
section environmental practices sound
environmental practices this is good but
now we're going on to lifelong learning
so as part of our lifelong learning we
need to
um improve and continue learning about
improving our environmental skills and
learning what new things as we get
new whatever
Technologies pesticide whatever it is
that we're working with um as we learn
new ways of of the appropriate way of
thinning forests or what two not to cut
or whatever that's a lifelong learning
thing so I think they're three steps of
that same piece that's
all okay further questions
discussion looks like we're there we got
several more bills
folks okay so with that we'll we'll
leave this one and put some amendments
together and we'll move move those
later okay that takes us through this
bill
148 we have S SP 135 and SB
19 take
Rick yeah yeah on 135 um uh I talk quite
a bit during the um during the hearing
on um two of the Amendments that um that
that that I'm going to offer uh next
week uh Amendment 1012 which um which
Returns the um fiscal capacity disparity
Equitable Grant to which we have in
fy21 stores that for fy22 and 23 it's
about a a $49 million um uh uh grant
that uh that goes to uh districts across
the state based on their um uh equalized
property value per pupil and um and
distribute State money in a in a re
really the places where it's needed most
as opposed to this sort of flat 50 Cent
um um you know tax reduction to
everybody whether or not you're tax
rates $40 per thousand or $4 per
thousand so it it it puts the money
where it makes the most difference the
other amendment that I'm going to offer
is is
1020h that um um does the same thing
it's an it's an equitable Grant it's
about an 11 million uh thing and it's um
it's um based on free and reduced price
lunch it's also something we did in a
very strong bipartisan way uh for
fy21 um last session and um and extends
that to fy22 and FY 23 it um uh uh both
both amendments are written so that you
know if one passes and the other doesn't
pass then the sunset provision that's in
current law applies um if they both pass
then the sunsets are extended to the uh
to the end of 20 well 6:30
uh 2023 so they're pushed out a year um
I am going to amend or make new versions
of these amendments because um we've had
some additional um uh information from
the from the the US um Department of of
Education with respect to the extension
of the free and reduced price lunch um
waivers so we're going to have to rely
on um on fy20 um uh uh uh free and
reduced price lunch headcounts the adma
for both the adequate adequacy
calculation as well as the um Equitable
Grant calculation uh going into fy22 and
FY 23 so we'll be amending um those two
changing those two amendments um to uh
to refle reflect that Dave Dave can you
hear me Dave can you hear me yeah um did
uh the feds now are saying yeah the
based on the
2020 I thought we um in uh
hb2 or sent over an amendment where we
went to
fy18
19 1819 where we'd have the option
taking the greater of fy19 I think it
was 19 and or the current so so it's not
fy9 you're talking about the fall of of
so the October
2019 yeah enrollment is the fy20
enrollment collected during the fall of
2019 I think either either we went there
was another amendment which I I bought
from Kaitlyn yeah so that's the third
grade reading Amendment that's Title One
yes yeah yes and I'm absolutely in
support of that one too and and uh and
that one would um would also need to to
apply to um um you know it would also
need to be changed so that it uses the
it it's already good at using the
2018 um or the sorry the U spring of 20
sorry I'm saying it the wrong way the
spring of 2019 numbers for the free for
the third grade reading
performance but but it also the way the
amendment's written is it's a replace
you know the entire bill with the new
thing so it also needs to reflect the
free and reduced price lunch uh for fy22
and FY 23 based on the fy20 data um uh I
I'm you
know I'm gonna I'm GNA take on all three
of these amendments I know the the one
for third grade reading has your name on
it but I'm happy
that one I I the day we discussed it
here in committee that was weeks ago
yeah that was the week prior to uh the
finance division two taking action or no
not F they' already they were taking
action and it was next week that Finance
acted upon
hb2 I believe they Incorporated the that
uh
Amendment uh Karen called me up umberger
represented umberger and asked for a
copy but that evening at 5 o'l I was
downstairs in the
LBA and that was emailed to her and I
believe they acted upon that in their
discussions the following week I don't
think they did Rick because we we we we
fought that on the
floor to get these amendments
in I'll have to check that because I
thought I was under the understanding
that that placed in because uh you
know so nothing in Senate Bill 135 or
the two or the three amendments that you
and I have talked about made their way
into hb2 it wasn't in I think they made
their own Amendment they took the
language and put it in another amendment
yeah but that that that policy didn't
make its way into hp2 but let's double
check that yeah yeah do that yeah um uh
but you know at the at the end of the
day
these three amendments um uh have a
price tag of um of of about 60 million a
year so $120 million for the
banum it they they they deploy State
funds where they're needed most both in
if to districts with high incidences of
poverty and to districts with with lower
uh property valuation per pupil and um
and and basically you know uses the um
the the money which would be would
instead be you know um done on a sort of
flat basis everybody gets the the same
thing and um um uh to uh to pay for it
so so the um you know uh anyway the the
amendments are going to have to
obviously be updated based on what we
just talked about from what we saw a few
weeks ago and um and I think it you know
know we we had discussion earlier this
this um you know at the beginning of the
session on on Rick on your bill House
Bill 608 which you know I think had a
lot of good intentions to it obviously
um a lot more um you know spreadsheet
work and modeling needs to be done but
but these three amendments certainly
push things in the direction of um of
you know that that I think house school
608 you know would take it and you'd see
you'd see you know Berlin seeing
potential uh tax rate reduction of over
$3.50 that's a
9% uh tax reduction there Charlestown
would see almost a
$3 uh tax reduction at 7 and a half%
Claremont 10% reduction and you know
Derry would even see a dollar you know
reduction on its um on its tax rate so
um you know so it really and you know
and Derry just joined the conval suit I
think I just heard that last night yes
they did yeah so um so you know
I you know I know it's been a long day
today so I I don't want to debate all
these things over again we've got next
week where where where we'll um bring
them up again but I'm I'm certainly
happy to take any questions uh Dave uh
when you come next week can we receive
beforehand do you have a a uh a
calculator there which would show
the information relative to all the
towns within the state yeah I've got a
I've got a what in fact what I what I
sent to the to the full committee a few
weeks ago were with those two amendments
as well as a um a town Bytown
spreadsheet uh I will send those again
uh with the updated you know amendments
the the numbers won't won't change just
the um uh you know it's just the ex use
of the pre-introduced price lunch adma
count um um for both for both years and
uh but I'll also include the um you know
I've updated the spreadsheet to also
show you know the potential tax rate
impact based on the Dr that's why I had
the Dr spreadsheet open uh this morning
and I'll make sure I'll make sure
everybody in the committee gets that by
Tuesday next week if I can um if I can
I'll get this over to Mary and
tomorrow they should be straightforward
changes and uh it yeah when you do those
calculations can you put average um the
average Actual taxes that people pay
because tax rate when you have different
tax valuation property valuation you
know you're going to have if you have a
low property valuation you need a much
higher rate to pay the same amount and
so what we really want to compare is
what people are actually paying because
like our T values down here are
ridiculously high that doesn't mean that
the people who live here have suddenly
started making lots more money or have
lots more money to pay it just means
that right at the moment our properties
are valued really high hasn't changed
our properties even it's the same
property it was you know five years ago
it's just suddenly worth more so then
our tax rate is less to to make the same
amount but when but so the question is
how much are people actually paying
that's what we want to see well it
depends on how how how you know valuable
your your your property is but the way
the way and and you know and um your
your um your constituent Sean Jasper um
explained this to me um a bunch of years
ago and the way you compare rates across
or between municipalities is by looking
at the equalized
um um rate uh because that that factors
in the the the local differences and
valuation or an assessment so yeah so
that's the that's the the rates that
that I use for comparison purposes are
equalized right but for for me if you
can in addition to that add in the the
average amount of taxes paid that will
help me see better because my 200y old
farmhouse we were just looking is worth
that quantities of money at the moment
it's still a 200y old farmhouse it's
just because it happens to exist in
Hudson which happens to be where people
want to move at the moment doesn't
change our income doesn't change our
house and so that's all I'm saying is so
where do you want me to get that data
well if you take the average tax rate
times the average property value that
should give you the average amount paid
right how do I get the average property
value well that's one of the things that
you had here was no that's Total
Property valuation oh so you don't know
what the average is you just know the
total yeah so so th this this data
actually can be mined I mean I do I do
have access to the data through the
Mosaic um Rick remember we we talked
about this on the school funding
commission the Mosaic
data has has every piece of um taxable
property in the state in New Hampshire
current valuation um um doesn't have tax
rate data but you can you can use that
that spreadsheets got 700,000 records on
it and you can use the Dr spreadsheet
with the with the tax rates and you can
actually you that could be calculated so
what I what I can do um Alicia is is
probably
for each
town I can probably calculate like the
number you know the the the tax impact
of let's say homes valued um less than
$300,000 between 300,000 and 500,000
500,000 to a million and a million and
up or something like that you know I I
I'll um I'll see if I can do it without
without my um computer CR yeah don't do
vast quantities of time and whatever but
that helps me see it better when I look
at it to say oh these guys are paying
$5,000 a year and these guys are paying
$2,000 a year that to me makes a it's
much more easy for me to understand
thank yeah yeah let me let me see what I
can do on on that there's um uh but I I
think I think what you're suggesting
though is is a good way where we I me
we've got access to these new you know
this these new tools and this data that
the Dr has started collecting and we can
actually use that when when when you
know to help us analyze policy like this
what does it do yeah thank you very
much rep you have a question just to
follow up on uh represent
leases one way to do it is look up each
town and you'll see the average value of
a house in the towns and for example in
Southern New Hampshire Hudson and
litfield for example a $300,000 house
there is
$150,000 house up in Berlin so if the
tax rate in Berlin is twice what
litfield is they're paying the same
amount of taxes and that's what Alicia
is trying to get to
so look at the equalized valuation but
that doesn't mean anything the property
values mean something and if you look at
each individual town they tell you what
the average
property is in that town and up north is
half of what it is in the South so is
the
income that doesn't matter resources
that doesn't
matter uh Dave uh the LBA put out a a
sheet which I I have right here you may
have it's stated
42721 it's estimated total education Aid
the House pass budget preliminary
estimates for discussion purpos only but
it was put out by the LBA do you have
anything that's been put out by the LBA
uh by what you're presenting um this
this goes down basically by every
municipality showing what they're
getting for fy22 and FY uh 23 compared
to the current year compared to
fy21 well for example fy22 is compared
to this the the current
law and and then um FY 23 as passed by
house is compared to the current law and
what what what does it show I'm not
looking at what you're looking at right
now what does it show for
fy22 um compared to fy21 current
law uh it shows for uh
fy22
m374
and for the current law it's 922
m666
547 it shows an increase of6 16,777,216
also have on my computer I can send it
to you
okay okay um so we know we're going to
have some amendments coming at us on uh
SB
135 uh is there any further discussion
on 135 at this
time yes representative ma uh thank you
Mr chair on these amendments uh
oftentimes during this past five months
uh we've got some of amendments like uh
1 minute to 9:00 or that type of thing
so whether they coming from whoever uh
you or or represent luno whoever uh and
I know they're busy at ol but if we
could get these like before the before
one minute to nine it would be really
good that's just well that that was the
purpose of having a work session today
so we could you know just have a
discussion all these bills and then you
know put some amendments out get it
going so we can get those in the hands
of folks prior to you know walking in
and find them it's that makes it
difficult for everybody um so let's
hopefully try and get them out as soon
as folks
can alrighty um so is there no more
discussion on SB
135 and that leaves the only remaining
we did 44 147 148 I mean and now we have
just the one bill
left
okay we we have Mark right there let's
hear from
mark thank you for putting your hand up
Mr
M good afternoon good afternoon Mark
sorry to to drag on your meeting I know
you've had a long day but um just want
to clarify something that was discussed
in the beginning um representative luno
is correct that um
there was efforts to get Senate Bill 135
in the budget and that was unsuccessful
was not put in the house budget um at
that time but just want to clarify what
representative lad was saying was the
third grade reading looking back to 2019
was put in House Bill too so the third
grade reading fix was put in House Bill
too that is in the house budget so I
just wanted to jump in and clarify that
that's what I was trying to say that
that amendment was put
in not under that amendment number I
don't believe it was may have been a
different you know Amendment correct no
but that that's also that's also has a
small sticker price you know on it
compared to the other adma adjustments
so okay Mark I have a question for you
I'm glad you're here um we we received
this uh estimated total education Aid uh
uh sheet put out by
LBA B basically uh uh uh March April
excuse April
2721 um and it shows fy22 FY 23 what the
current law is what the house passed
increases decreases have you seen in
your department or do you have a
spreadsheet that shows the individual
communities and shows the adequacy
formula right across how all this was
calculated so comparing current law um
yeah I think I produced that document uh
or I have a document a similar not the
lb's document but a doe document I can
look um to see what I have but when you
look at current law which was that 922
Million number and then you have the
governor's um which in the governor's
formula which is essentially house bill
to was adopted um it's a $16 million
increase over current law um I can I can
produce that document okay see i' I've
asked you know I got this quick look
sheet but I was looking for the you know
a more thorough uh spreadsheet which
showed the you know is that possible if
you have it to uh email a copy of that
to members on the committee yep I think
I think I have what you're looking for I
don't know if I exactly have it but I
have I have something it might be yeah
and and clarification on that two Mark
current law is $90 million less than
fy21 approximately approximately yes
approximately current law 9 million less
than fy21 so this is you know this is
money that um that that a lot of
districts are going to have to make up
for with local property taxes if is that
including Dave the the onetime money yes
and how much is that total up to about
what about half of it yeah it's about
50 $ 59 million something like that I
rounded it off to 60 yeah
yeah so the the difference between the
two is you're talking talking $30
million yeah that's the that's the adma
the the the the um pandemic um uh
related
costs okay and how much money are we
getting in are the towns getting in for
the pandemic like from the federal
government or wherever towards that
30,000 only only the city I I think
we've only seen that report for
cities I don't think we've seen it for
um school districts or towns yet but I
think or or it's just come
out Mark do you do you
have I have a document that we presented
to house finance um it doesn't include
all the allocations I think in total
we're talking about $600 million in
federal money coming in um we haven't
done all of the dispersements and
allocations but I can provide a document
on that as
well that'd be
nice okay uh any other questions for
Mark from doe works with
Caitlyn thanks Mark for showing up thank
you have a good afternoon you
too okay uh so 135 we will discuss that
one too uh uh we have one other bill
Senate Bill
19 which is the Signum bill I don't
think we need a long work session on
that right now um the the house bill is
enrolled at this point in
time so there's basically I don't think
we need to work on that at all
no other words you know it the it's
going to happen it's just now um govern
sign yeah we're just probably most
likely itl the Signum bill
yeah alrighty any other points oh I also
also um um while we have people
here we have uh two Committee of
conference
requests and I'll give you the bill
numbers that's so much paperwork on this
desk I always spread out too
much here they are nearest ones to me
um HB
320 requires a Civics competency
assessment as high school graduation
requirement so that has come back to us
with an amended change the amendment is
simply to change the effective date to
July 1
2023 everything else in it remained the
same uh it's the effective date July 1
um what I have to do is I will I have to
get a uh a poll actually the chairman of
the committee can make a decision but
I've always worked with committee
members and try to get a reasonable
understanding where committee is on it
and then to make a decision whether
we're going to concur non-c concur or
non-c Concur and request a committee of
conference and then we appoint members
to that Committee of
conference um so that's the first one it
was
320 uh the the second bill is HB
432 relative to the offenses that
prevent employment in a
school and there
were uh some significant changes to this
bill so uh what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna get this and send it out to you
and read it over then I will be polling
people to find out you know where we
stand on these two bills uh I want to
get these Committee of conference going
because we're going to have more bills
coming in from the Senate and we're
going to have to get all this business
taken care of
here so look for these two bills I'll be
sending you 320 and
432 Rick can I ask a question yeah um so
uh 4:32 I was actually present during
that Senate uh hearing and exec session
y so I I know about the changes to that
bill um
um what's what's our timeline on this
like when when do you see us making
decisions on this will we discuss this
before uh decisions are made the the way
we've always done Committee of
conferences before we usually are in the
hall you pull people down to one section
or area of it you explain it and a
decision's made right there uh We've
also done it the other way where we've
discussed them in committee um most
likely on this one I will poll everybody
or try to get together with everybody at
a time and and we can explain them and
and then a recommendation can come
forward to me and then I make a
recommendation to the the speaker um
once the if we decide to concur it's
done it goes on to the the governor uh
if we non-c concur then the the or
excuse me concur if we concur it goes to
to the the house floor for a vote and
you'll if you've been in the house
before you know that there's a whole
Litany of these bills a myriad of bills
and we have just go down quickly and do
the voice votes usually sometimes it's a
roll call vote non-c concur is the same
issue uh it goes before the house non-c
Concur and request Committee of
conference when you do that then we have
the committee of conference and then
that comes back to the uh the Full House
with that recommendation or can be
killed other words you know we don't
agree with the senate or the Senate
doesn't agree with us I've been in a
number of those I was in one Committee
of the conference dealing with one of
the issues years ago and we we went
through 30 amendments in the committee
of conference and end up killing the
bill nobody could agree
so so it's it's it's a process which can
be very interesting but time taking we
have to have this done commit of
conference period starts generally
speaking couple weeks before um the last
session because she got to act on this
stuff and the committee conferences all
have to be scheduled during that time
they out all the rooms in the L for
committee of conferences and nothing
else goes
on so all right well I'm happy to answer
any questions if anybody has them about
4:32 as I said I was there so uh if
anybody qu reads it and looks through it
and says how are these two things
related or whatever I mean I'm happy to
answer those questions okay generally
speaking when a committee of conference
is developed the chair will appoint
members to it there's one member that
will be appointed from the uh minority
Democratic party usually and most
importantly the chair will look for some
of the voted positively for the
bill um I've seen where members of the
committee conference have been kicked
off um uh you know of the committee of
conference not literally but yeah like
uh oh you better warn me about that Rick
because I could be one of those people I
can remember when when the Republicans
were in the minority and we had some
folks that would not agree to the
finance report and they were kicked off
and you know and so it happens both ways
so we won't literally do that
all right and I promise I'll keep my
sense of humor in
check good good that Manchester humor
right okay so I think that takes us
through everything for
today anything else we're gonna have to
wake Ralph up over
there he's already out the
door so thank you very much and we'll
call it quits today and if you get some
amending language please get it to
everybody as soon as
can I have a good weekend everybody yeah